what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so spider-man homecoming comes out
in July yet after finishing the
Incredible Hulk a lot of people really
seem to enjoy the idea of like long
series like picking a character a team
or something like that and just doing
like an entire run just covering like
when one writer takes over the title and
just does like a whole run you know Greg
packs Incredible Hulk is a really good
example it's also the reason why I think
I'm gonna go ahead and dive into it but
it's also the reason why we're gonna do
Geoff Johns Green Lantern because it was
it was so good that's gonna take like a
year and a half to finish it's insane
how long it is um but that's also what
we're doing in Justice is because you
know they're really popular runs people
really enjoy them I really enjoy them
and so I figured I'd go ahead and cover
them but with spider-man homecoming
coming out in July I intended to do
all-new all-different amazing spider-man
you know when when spider-man homecoming
came out but after you know the idea of
people loving The Incredible Hulk so
much I sat down and I said okay well the
issue with spider-man only while
different amazing spider-man is that is
the fact that it's basically just a
continuation of dance lots run from when
he first took over the title it's all
just one great big huge giant story and
so because of that I kind of figured
well I mean why not go back and do dance
slots run because it really starts with
spider-man big time you know picking
Peter Parker back to his roots the way
he should be in the eyes of Dan Slott
and really in the eyes of a lot of fans
and then basically moving forward all
the way through the events of Spider
Island all the way through the events of
superior spider-man spider-man basically
ending with all nude or really kind of
picking up with all-new all-different
amazing spider-man by the time the movie
comes out that's what I'm shooting for
here and the way I have it scheduled it
should work out you know I mean coming
out every Monday it would just be a
Spider Man video running up until only
while different amazing spider-man fight
in July but a couple things that I want
to run over here as we get into this is
really J michael Straczynski is run i
don't want to go super in-depth into it
but there are a few things that we need
to highlight our first and foremost was
one more day one more day is one of the
most divisive stories among spider-man
fans I mean there are a lot of people
that just hate it they hate hate hate it
usually it's because you know people who
picked up spider-man before the events
of one more day so they were reading
about the marriage and the struggles and
trials and tribulations between Peter
Parker and Mary Jane Watson they came to
identify with him they loved the
marriage between the two of them I mean
Peter and Mary Jane Watson were never
like Superman and Lois Lane level couple
but they were the most popular couple in
Marvel Comics they were kind of like
Marvel's power couple in a lot of
different ways there were a few people
who just hopped on the bandwagon they
just hate it one more day because it was
the popular thing to do but if you were
one of those
people who you know went back in red
spider-man before the events of one more
day and then went through one more day
and picked up after a lot of people
hated it but after the events of one
more day there was brand new dip and
brand new day basically said here's the
new starting point for Peter Parker and
people hated that just as much as they
hated hated one more day because he
basically said now you know Peter Parker
and Mary Jane Watson are no longer
married they basically ended their
marriage by selling it off more or less
to Mephisto in order to make sure that
Aunt May lived because of the fact that
she was dying at the time who was
granting on May a new lease on life now
with brand new day going forward
Straczynski made a lot of changes one of
the first things he did is he took the
character of Aunt May and said okay
she's been single and alone long enough
you know ever since Peter Parker was
first introduced Uncle Ben had died and
she's basically been alone for the last
40 some-odd years let's give her someone
and so what he did is he basically gave
her he paired her up with a Jay jonah
Jameson senior the father of Jay jonah
Jameson the you know the head of Daily
Bugle that hates Peter Parker and so
because of this the two of them
basically paired off fans you know there
were fans who loved it fans who hated it
it was kind of a mixed reaction uh but
then and he you know J michael
Straczynski also got rid of the Daily
Bugle and the way he did this was by
interjecting stories of Jay jonah
Jameson having heart attacks different
things like that but it was basically
the idea that the Daily Bugle had been
struggling and so what happened was a
financier got by the name of Daniel
Bennett I think it was I came along and
basically bought it now it was done
against the will of Jay jonah Jameson
and in fact he was hospitalized at the
time that it actually happened instead
he was really Jay jonah Jameson's wife
Marla who engineered the selling of The
Daily Bugle but essentially this this
more or less
led to everybody being sent off I mean
it was really people just not really
being tied into the Daily Bugle and so
because it was removed from the
landscape in a lot of ways but then we
also had Peter Parker now Peter Parker
and Jay jonah Jameson one of the cool
things that Straczynski focused on was
this notion that the two of them had
this kind of respect you know Jay jonah
Jameson always looked at Peter Parker as
is not really a surrogate son but
somebody that he had a lot of respect
for the issue with this was that when
Peter Parker revealed his identity
during the events of civil war Jay jonah
Jameson flipped he hit the roof and what
it did is it shattered to trust that he
had in Peter Parker and it more or less
you know printed a vendetta and stronger
than it had ever been between between
Jay jonah Jameson Peter Parker and
spider-man and so what happened his
eventually spider-man basically saves
the life of Jay jonah Jameson
during an encounter with the vulture but
a security guard had sacrificed his life
in the process to you know try to
protect Jameson and while Jameson looked
at the death of the security guard I
said that was honorable that was a great
thing that he did Peter Parker doctored
a photo to make it look like Jameson had
fought off the vulture and so what
happened is Jameson took this as an
affront and said basically you're
insulting the identity of the security
guard you restore to the memory of the
security guard who basically saved my
life and so Peter Parker was essentially
a ousted from the Daily Bugle and so
that's why he's currently unemployed
when it comes to this so there were a
couple things that were introduced here
and there and we'll cross that bridge
when we get to you but with regards to
expired a man big time this is really
again Dan Slott making Peter Parker his
own now keep in mind this is all after
the events of civil wars so on and so
forth you know Steve Rogers has already
returned to the landscape and so what
this does is it gives us the Avengers
that really the Mighty Avengers as it
exists right now with Thor Jessica drew
Spider Woman you know Iron Man Wolverine
Captain America hawkeye so on and so
forth and they're basically responding
to the robots of Doctor Octopus wreaking
havoc in New York now this is really bad
slot leading up to the events of
superior spider-man when Otto Octavius
took over the body of Peter Parker
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
people loved the early run of Dan Slott
because there were so many plot threads
that started in Big Time and extend it
out into everything and it took you know
four or five years in order for it to
all come to fruition but when it did it
felt rewarding I felt like this great
big huge incredible experience and so um
really what the various superheroes
going through and and fighting against
you know these guys you pick up with Jay
jonah Jameson and again with tomorrow
and now of course because of the trials
and tribulations they'd experienced they
were going through couples counseling
different things like that but again
it's really just Dan Slott saying hey
here's what we reside we have Jay jonah
Jameson as mayor right now we have him
and Marla dealing with with family
issues you know dealing with with couple
issues as again you know taking taking
the stories very much back to the
grounded level of traditional
superheroes and traditional characters
as we knew them albeit in some slightly
different roles but what we do at this
point is we pick up with with Captain
America now within this story this is
really just kind of a not really a side
plot but kind of a side thing but it
really ties in a Doctor Octopus but this
is a small version of what I'm talking
about when I talk about you know
instances where Dan slots building into
bigger things because this is not
actually Steve Rogers instead what
happens to see Rogers tells this guy who
is standing guard with regards to this
vertex shuttle to basically go away you
know
Hey look you're you're relieved of
relief of guard duty you know I'm gonna
go ahead and take over here just because
of the fact that this is one of the most
important artifacts that we have right
now not amiable and you can just keep an
eye on and of course the other cool
thing here is Dan Slott builds on the
legacy of Captain America that's one of
the interesting things here is in Marvel
Comics you have characters that are
interchangeable and you have characters
that are concrete characters that do not
change uh some characters that are
interchangeable might be like Moon
Knight for example different riders can
can take a different view of the
character right him differently bring in
characters remove characters things like
that Steve Rogers is not that way he's a
concrete character and he's always the
guy who's like freedom freedom above all
else he always fights for freedom he
never fights for anything other than
freedom that's the biggest reason why
the the change of Steve Rogers becoming
a Hydra agent during all-new
all-different model was so uh so
controversial is because there are a lot
of people who are clinging on to these
old stories and didn't want to see the
the Steve Rogers concept move forward
didn't really want to see a change they
wanted him to stay Captain America and
rightfully so because people latch on to
different aspects of different
characters as time goes on and the one
that they love the most is the one they
don't want to see change so it's it's
natural to have that kind of response
but again picking back up with Peter
Parker that we basically joined Felicia
as showing with the arrival of Felicia
Hardy now she doesn't get a whole lot of
screen time here in the opening salvo
for Big John she actually becomes
important later on down the line but
again oh she's just one of the funny
members one of the members of the spider
family so to speak but there's also a
little banter back in here and again
this is really just Dan Slott saying hey
Felicia Hardy she's one of the
characters that you all know and love
she's definitely gonna play a major role
in this story it's a result it's always
kind of fun to see but the other the
other funny thing here is she arrives on
the scene to help Peter Parker you know
bail him out of an otherwise dangerous
situation and she's like yeah so what's
the chances of me becoming an Avenger
and Peter Parker of course is like none
there's no chance of you becoming an
Avenger there's there's not a single
solitary chance sorry that's your luck
but again from here the cool thing and
one of the things I love the most about
Dan slots writing when it came to to
this opening you know this opening thing
was really the idea of how Peter Parker
sees himself because what he does is he
sits down he says hey look you know I
basically have a new life going on now
you know I'm I'm with my new girlfriend
you know Carly Cooper I'm not with Mary
Jane Watson anymore you know he talks
about the idea of Aunt May being in a
relationship with Jay jonah Jameson
senior but he also addresses himself in
relation to other superheroes you know
he says he's not a heavy hitter like
Thor you know he's
one of the big-time geniuses like Reed
Richards or Tony Stark but that's the
irony of this is that he very much is
you know Peter Parker is extremely smart
he's one of the smartest men out there
and it's really this sort of humble
nature that people that people like you
know where he doesn't sit down and say
yeah I'm one of the smartest people out
there you know it's always the idea that
in his mind there's always someone
smarter there's always someone out there
that's capable of more but we as the
reader know that that's not really the
case that spider-man is one of the
smartest people out there now at this
point we pick back up again with Andrew
Air Force Base and again this is
basically the chameleon who is
masquerading as Steve Rogers and the
reason why is because they're basically
carrying out a mission on behalf of
Doctor Octopus now again this is Doctor
Octopus setting the stage for some much
grander plans later on down the line
he's basically implementing his own
scheme on the side this entire conflict
here is essentially designed to be a
distraction not only that you know
Doctor Octopus actually has a lot of
respect for Peter Parker this is why I
say this is Dan Slott setting the stage
for Doctor Octopus taking over the mind
of Peter Parker doing superior
spider-man because what he says is you
know at this moment right now Peter
Parker is really really smart but Doctor
Octopus also recognizes that a time will
come where at least in this almost
immediate moment that Peter Parker is
going to find a way to basically
deactivate all these different bombs
that he has planted inside these devices
around New York and this is why I say
that Peter Parker is just as smart as
Reed Richards and Tony Stark because
what he does is he sits and says oh my
god I figured out what's going on
because in their mind you know in the
mind of Reed Richards and Stark and so
on this countdown is going and when it
reaches zero all these bombs are gonna
go off and New York is going to vanish
off the face of the earth but what Peter
Parker realizes is that it's the first
day of November that is basically
daylight savings time and so you know
dr. Octavius or dr. octopus to taking
this into account that when Peter Parker
figured out what was going on that he
would be able to set the timer back and
give them an extra hour now this of
course allows Peter Parker and the
various members of the Avengers to get
these bombs out of here but again this
was all just designed to be a ruse it
was designed to keep them focused on
this one thing so that dr. octopus could
implement his own plans and what we'll
find out with those plans will be later
on but from here we transition to
frontline now again this is all part of
the post-civil war Lance can't remember
frontline came to prominence with Ben
Urich and Sally Floyd Ames during Civil
War and it got a lot of popularity
because it was basically covering the
events of Civil War from the
perspective of reporters from non
superheroes basically and because of
that Ben Urich and Sally Floyd
eventually lucked The Daily Bugle where
they originally started out they took
the front line concept with them
basically this online posting source and
they launched their own publication
house called frontline and that's what's
happening with a lot of people here a
lot of folks like Robbie Robertson you
know they are all taking up residence as
part of frontline in place of The Daily
Bugle and so because of that you know we
again pick back up with with Peter
Parker and the funny thing about this is
again during dance slots run there was a
girl named Michelle and she had
essentially become Peter Parker's
roommate to a degree and they were they
really had a relationship although it
was more of a physical one really than
an actual you know we love each other on
a solid scale but ditches came by way of
Michelle's brother you know being
convicted of a crime you know and her
keeping an eye on her brother's place
while he was gone Peter Parker of course
having been roommates with her brother
before he was incarcerated ah but this
is again Dan Slott wrapping all these
things up and acting all these things
removing them from the landscape because
what happens is Peter comes home and
Michelle is like yeah I'm going back to
Chicago now because my brother's out and
so you know that's that's pretty much it
and so Peter Parker is more or less just
kind of left to call around to different
people and see if he can find a roommate
see if he could find a place to take up
residence now that's the cool thing here
is because this is Peter Parker just
struggling with everyday things like
well my roommates gone so I got to find
a new place and he's got to do a quick
fast and in a hurry of course he goes to
Carly but their relationship is still
pretty new and so she's like look I mean
we more or less just started dating not
too long ago I'm not really comfortable
with moving in and so she basically says
no which is kind of messed up of course
he goes to Flash Thompson and flash
Thompson's like no that's not gonna
happen man like you you're you're not
gonna live with me and he even goes to
Mary Jane Watson you know the funny
thing about this is Dan Slott it was it
was really kind of a funny moment
because it was like Dan Slott was toying
with fans it's like he was trolling Mary
Jane Watson fans like hey you know how
you guys really really want to see Peter
Parker and Mary Jane wants to get back
together a fans are like yeah he's like
that's not gonna happen and so like you
know he ends up having to leave years of
walking away you know when the two of
them agreed not to be roommates together
and so ultimately he goes to he goes to
on may now the cool thing about this is
that Aunt May was already spending time
or at least already hanging out with the
son of Jay jonah Jameson along with Jay
jonah Jameson senior you know the two of
them you know spending time with one
another hanging out as well as a woman
by the name of dr. Madison Jamison now
the reason why Madison Jamison matters
here is because Aunt May was
telling her about Peter Parker saying
hey you know my my Peter Parker is a
genius you know he's one of the smartest
people on the face of the planet and so
by the time Peter Parker arrives starts
knocking on the door of Aunt May it says
hey would it be possible for me to crash
here dr. Madison says actually you're
amazed basically said that you're a
genius
and I know of a guy who's very good at
dealing with geniuses and so what
happens is Peter Parker is taken to
Horizon labs now for those of you guys
who were reading all-new all-different
amazing spider-man and the first story
arc saw the marriage of Max Modell and
his significance there what this was was
a continuation of this whole horizon lab
story this is where all this starts is
this full horizon labs thing it's the
introduction of this we kind of get the
kicker that's that's why I really wanted
to cover this is really exciting
you guys will basically get everything
that led to all-new all-different
amazing spider-man from the ground up
like you guys get it from the very
beginning which is why it's so cool but
horizon labs as it's led by Max Modell
is like Peter Parker's playgrounds
that's the best way to describe it max
Modell according to Peter Parker was
really his idol in a lot of different
ways I mean Peter look to Reed Richards
he looked at Tony Stark yeah they're
really smart they're capable of great
things but in his mind
max Modell was the guy to aspire to not
only that we get the introduction of a
really cool guy named Grady Grady scraps
and I love greedy scraps but the gist of
this is that horizon labs is essentially
a think-tank for some of the smartest
people in the Marvel Universe this
really all it is is it just it's a
think-tank for all these geniuses and so
it's a chance for them to just kind of
run free and do whatever they want to
now what what max Modell says is that
the way this is done or the way horizon
labs functions is different than like
Reed Richards future foundation it's
different then like 20 starts whole
initiative the idea isn't to necessarily
say all right guys your assignment is to
focus on this one thing and then go from
there it's basically hey do whatever you
want to do like just create whatever you
want to create just get carried away let
your imagination run wild because
creativity only really comes when there
is no constraint here when there's no
confinement here and so what is up
happening is we basically pick up with a
woman may miss us a Johnny joffrey who's
basically trying to create an artificial
version of vibranium now the reason why
she's doing this is because this story
takes place after an event called do
more and do more was a story where
Doctor Doom invaded Wakanda for the
purpose of capturing its vibranium now
while
you know what Conda its citizens are
basically placed under control you know
they were dominated that kind of thing
black panther and his sister Cherie were
the only ones who remain out of the
influence of this fear of control and so
in the end it was you know they were
successful in casting out dr. doom but
in the process black panther basically
rendered all the vibranium across the
world in urk
and so this had to two effects the first
is that ever all vibranium everywhere
which had the mystical property of
absorbing kinetic energy it basically
rendered all that obsolete so now
vibranium was essentially worthless the
other effect was that because vibranium
was basically worthless Wakanda had no
real value anymore and so what's
happening is people are basically
scrambling to try to find vibranium
trying to find a way to duplicate it
that's what was happening here the issue
is that so Jonny's created something
called reverb Ian instead of absorbing
sound instead of absorbing energy it
reflects it and it amplifies it and so
essentially it's like it's like turning
the whole thing into a tuning fork and
that's really what happens here as soon
as it's activated it's just like
infinite amplification of sound to the
point that it threatens to bring the
entire building crashing down around it
now of course Peter Parker is able to
able to shut the system down and so what
happens is he's kind of given this pop
quiz by max Modell the funny thing about
this is that when they ask him questions
like well you know we've developed an
antigravity harness what are we used for
a braking system you know when he's
asked questions like how do you contain
a 3d object or a 2d object in a 3d space
you know when they're talking about how
did you know we've discovered some alien
fungus how do you how do you slow its
growth he references his own experiences
here what he's dealing with vulture when
he's dealing with with venom he's
referencing his own experience and going
against these various villains and how
he was able to defeat them and so really
is him bringing his own experience to
the table and this is Dan Slott saying
no no Peter Parker's a genius he's one
of the smartest people out there and so
for me here it's really spider-man
hitting the big time it's the idea that
he's experienced he's finally
experiencing success he's finally having
things go his way and so as this little
bit begins to wrap up we're basically
brought back or at least were
reintroduced to the character of
Roderick Kingsley also known as the
Hobgoblin now the cool thing about the
Hobgoblin is that he was actually
created by Roger stern to basically be a
replacement for the Green Goblin the way
it worked out is in 1971 a Gerry Conway
had written a story called the night
Gwen Stacy died and that was the death
of Gwen Stacy he was one of the most
landmark stories in the history of Peter
Parker but basically it ended with the
death of the
Goblin the issue was that Green Goblin
was so popular by that point or at least
the idea of the Oh Wednesday's he died
because of either the actions of the
Green Goblin or Spider Man was such a
controversial topic that's still being
debated to this day that Marvel wanted
to bring the Green Goblin back but at
the time with Rogers Stern riding
amazing spider-man his idea was I do not
want to bring the Green Goblin back from
the dead instead I'm gonna create
somebody else and enter the Hobgoblin
now there have been different people who
have played the role of Hobgoblin and
they've all had different aspects of the
character that made them all unique but
for the character of King occasionally
and really for Hobgoblin as whole while
he has come into contact with Peter
Parker on several occasions he always
really seem more like a mercenary than
anything else you know kind of like a
soldier of fortune in the sense that he
would just take contracts he would
implement those contracts and that would
be it now with regards to Hobgoblin as
he exists right now he's been contracted
by kingpin and the reason for this is
because kingpin you know has sources on
the inside there's guys on the inside of
horizon labs and kingpin comes to the
realization that you know Joffrey is
basically working on reverb IAM and
kingpin basically says hey look if this
is a metal that can amplify sound then
what we're going to do is we're gonna
steal it and we're literally gonna
weaponize it and then sell it to any
government that wants to buy it again
it's really just you know it's it's pure
it's just pure money running here when
it comes to kingpin that's really all
that's that's really all this aspect of
the story is but what happens if
Kingsley travels to what used to be the
domain of Norman Osborn because keep in
mind you know this is after the events
of Dark Reign this is after the events
of siege and so Norman Osborn is no
longer a main character instead he's
very much just gone from the public eye
and so because of that you know when
Kingsley actually gets into Norman
Osborn's lab and starts going through
his personal things he's met by Phil
uric now Phil uric is one of the people
who was associated with with the Daily
Bugle and his whole idea is that he's
basically the nephew of the now famous
Ben Urich who did so much reporting
during the events of civil war but what
happens is Phil uric while he's being
attacked by a Hobgoblin essentially just
freaks
now with Phil uric the funny thing about
him is that he was a goblin at one point
in time in fact he was the Green Goblin
during the events of the onslaught saga
so it's not like he's brand new to all
this he's not a creation by Dan Slott
instead for the character of failure
this is a return to familiarity in a lot
of different ways they said now he's
taking on the role of hobgoblins now as
far as I'm aware the only Goblin
roll that pill jerk played up to this
point was the Green Goblin I may be
wrong although I don't think I am but if
I am feel free to uh feel free to
correct me down there but as far as I'm
aware he was only ever only ever the
Green Goblin but taking over the role of
Hobgoblin was really interesting about
this is that it really shines into
effect the nature of the kingpin in the
sense that kingpin doesn't really care
who it is if it fills a contract as long
as what he's trying to acquire is
brought in you know as long as what it
is that he's looking for is brought to
him now at this point we basically pick
up in City Hall and again this is really
kind of funny here because Jay John and
Jameson still hates the idea of
spider-man I mean he's always going to
hate spider-man and was kind of cool as
Captain America shows up and says hey
look I really want spider-man to receive
like you're doing the whole honorary
thing of the key to the city
I really think spider-man should be the
one to get this now this immediately
strikes you know this immediately
strikes Jay jonah Jameson has done
enough that's not gonna happen
absolutely hates by a man I'm not going
to give it to him I'm going to give it I
gonna give it to my son now the funny
thing about this is that his son shows
up you know and he says hey you know I
would love to have the key to the city
but I really do think it needs to go to
spider-man because he's done so many
great deeds so it's not the most
significant thing in the world it's just
kind of uh it's kind of funny to see Jay
jonah Jameson being put in such a
strange situation but again piggy back
up again with with horizon labs this is
when we really start to get this full
explanation from maximo down the since
we're introduced to a few other
characters here and there you know a few
more members which is part of the the
elite seven of the not realize the
secret seven but it's part of like the
top seven people who were they're the
ones that can come and go as they please
work on whatever it is that they want to
and Peter Parker's basically given his
own lab he's given the ability to work
on whatever it is that he wants to work
on the issue with this is that while
he's in the middle of studying while
he's in the middle of reading what he
needs to read and try to get things in
order the entire horizon last facility
is immediately attacked by the Hobgoblin
now this was actually kind of cool
because Dan Slott was messing around
with us a little bit I mean we would sit
here and we would think well this is
these are some of the smartest people on
the face of the planet
and so if Peter Parker suddenly not
there and spider-man is there did it
would seem like the easiest thing to
figure out of the easiest thing to
understand her to you know come to the
conclusion of is that Peter Parker is
spider-man not only that you remember
Phil Urich has his no goblins scream so
to speak which basically you know it did
cause it Reese all kinds of havoc and
the sense that is basically a sonic
scream and so because of this it
incapacitates Peter Parker you know it
causes physical reactions
he's bleeding out of his eyes you know
and so what happens is in the middle of
this conflict Peter Parker is able to
make his escape by the the skin of his
pants
max Modell Yanks the fire alarm and what
it does is it kind of balances things
out of it in the sense that it more or
less ends you know the hobgoblin off
just kind of running for the middle of
nowhere spider-man of course chases
after him and it's kind of this
cat-and-mouse game and this sense of
spider-man's trying to figure out why
hobgoblins come back he's trying to
figure out while he's there but in the
end it doesn't really matter because
Hobgoblin is able to make off with this
a reverb IAM as has been created by so
Johnny Joffrey and so one of the funny
moments here this is this is why I love
this so much is at this point you know
once it's all said and done we have
captain captain Watanabe of the of the
New York Police Department that shows up
and of course I Peter Parker changing
out of his spider-man uniform has to
come up with an excuse for why it is
that he wasn't out there when one of the
people was like hey I took a headcount
and Peter Parker's not here when they go
into his lab he's wearing headphones and
he's naked and his response is that well
this is how I function like I put
headphones on I listen to music you know
I I study when I'm naked it was the only
excuse that he could come up with
spur-of-the-moment and this is why so
many fans loved Peter Parker cuz it was
just small moments like this that were
absolutely hilarious it was small
moments like this that we're amazing but
at this point we pick up with Hobgoblin
joining Wilson Fisk er this is why I say
Wilson Fisk
it doesn't really care what goes on with
a contract I said he says where's
Roderick Kingsley
like where's Kingsley at and the
response of you know Phil uric Hobgoblin
is it doesn't really matter like it
doesn't matter at all I mean he's gone
he's dead you know but the contracts
been fulfilled and kingpin says cool
beans now the funny thing is he doesn't
really trust Kingsley that much he's not
really sure how he feels about him but
he did uphold the contract he did
fulfill what it was that kingpin was
looking for and that's all he ever
really cares about now at this point we
rejoin blackhat and that's why I say she
was gonna have more of a significant
role later on in the story and I love
what Dan Slott does with this
historically speaking has always been
this sort of cat-and-mouse game not to
make a pun but there's always been the
sort of cat-and-mouse game between Peter
Parker and an in black hat in the sense
but it was always a sort of will they
won't they kind of thing you know like
are they ever gonna get together are
they ever gonna actually have any real
measure of an ongoing relationship and
that's really what Dan Slott does here
you toys with the notion there's a lot
of sexual tension between two of them
and a lot of jokes that go on between
the two of them but at the end of the
day it's always Peter Parker saying hey
this is why we don't
this is what we don't get together but
what blackhat also says is that by way
of her sources she's come to the to the
realization or she's been informed that
the buyer of the reverb the reverb iam
that was stolen from a horizon labs its
kingpin so this really brings Spider Man
back into contact with Wilson Fisk again
now at this point you know he says of
course you know meet me at this location
the two of them end up getting together
and a box just lands behind black count
where she opens it up
there's glasses there's an earpiece
glasses they put this on with a guard
once they put this on you know when she
does she realizes is that Peter Parker
has a new suit that he basically has a
stealth suit and what he says is this
suit is designed to eliminate sound and
eliminate people being able to see him
and this incident it minimizes all of it
and so I guess minimizes all of his face
as it was really his own stealth
variation of what a Tony Stark had done
before where he had made a stealth suit
and so this basically allows them to
infiltrate you know infiltrate kingpins
base of operations in Shadow Man and
attempt to try to retrieve the reverb
iam now somebody else to keep in mind
here is that at this point again you
know field Jurgis Hobgoblin is very much
in the employ of kingpin not to mention
that kingpin himself also has you know
members of the hand now something I want
to point out here is that the hand is
this really clandestine organization of
ninjas based out of Japan that go back
quite some time but overall the gist is
twofold when it comes to the hand the
first is to to infiltrate various you
know governmental agencies subvert them
from the inside out operate from the
shadows that kind of thing but they're
basically also for hire in the sense
that if you have enough money you can
hire you can pay members of the hand to
carry out assassinations woe betide you
if you don't pay them but you can you
can hire them for the purpose of making
assassinations being bodyguards things
like that and that's kind of the
interesting thing is because the hand
are some of the best assassins in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe and so
if you have them as bodyguards you're
almost guaranteed to stay safe only with
the exception of a few people who are
there who can basically subvert them
Wolverine is a good example Elektra is a
good example different things like that
but in the midst of all this with
Hobgoblin you know basically responding
to what seems to be a break-in with you
know Peter Parker arriving here along
with black hat black hat actually leaves
Peter hanging she kind of bails out in
the middle of it as if hey like you know
I was here to help you get this but I'm
literally a cat burglar and I know a
losing game when I see one so you're on
your own and she says all I'm gonna do
is go to you know
Wilson Fisk personal office steal some
of this profit
collection and then sell it of course
Wilson Fisk's a head of security so to
speak figures out what's going on with
black hat you know he's able to say to
subdue her and when she's in the
clutches of kingpin the funny thing
about this is that you know Peter
Parker's suit is designed to block out
all methods of communication not only
that Hobgoblin had basically used his
sonic scream in order to overpower this
stealth suit or the stealth aspect of
Peter Parker's suit which he responds in
kind by again basically blocking out all
sound and were to keep the Hobgoblin
sonic scream from affecting him but the
issue here is that he's oblivious to
what's going on with regards to Felicia
Hardy he has no idea what's happening
with regards to her being taken by the
kingpin and so in the end what really
ends up happening here it's just a
matter of circumstance that leads to
Felicia Hardy you know getting free
spider-man being able to make his escape
in the sense that the the sonic scream
of Hobgoblin reflects off the the reverb
IAM and literally begins to start
bringing the building crashing down
around him so of course Peter is able to
jump in he's able to save Felicia he
goes against a kingpin for a little
while but that's really about it I mean
really just kind of whisks out of there
and he calls it a day and so in response
we we basically wrapped this section up
with Dan Slott kind of you know leaving
us a bit of a taste for what comes next
when we have to fill Urich meeting with
everybody at the Daily Bugle you know
Robbie Robertson and all these guys back
in the Daily Bugle again as well as him
being me you know basically being the
Inside Man in the sense that he
essentially knows everything that's
going on when it comes to the Daily
Bugle
he knows what Peter Parker's individual
actions are despite not knowing that
Peter and spider-man and one in the same
it's really always him just kind of
operating from the shadows and what
dance law is basically doing is drawing
a parallel between Peter Parker and
Hobgoblin Phil Urich in the sense of
saying that you know in a lot of ways
Phil Urich is this the sort of Peter
Parker antithesis in a sense that Peter
Parker was working as a Daily Bugle with
a dual identity he was Peter Parker he
was spider-man he was selling photos to
the Daily Bugle to show what it was that
he was doing or at least to show what
spider-man was doing as how he was
making his money
Hobgoblin is doing much the same thing
except instead of making money he's
using it to bolster his reputation
meanwhile Peter Parker has basically
moved on for the Daily Bugle and he's
taking up residence in Horizon lives
where he's basically making his money
now he's making a lot of it but this
really kind of ends with the idea of you
know basically Peter Parker's all new
apartment is essentially a Dan Slott
saying here's where we are now Peter
Parker's got his own place he's got his
own girlfriend that's not married
watson that for him all is right with
the world and it lives up to the title
spiderman big time in the sense of Peter
Parker has finally hit the big time
he's finally stepped into what he
considers to be a successful career that
he's no longer scrounging by by selling
photographs to the Daily Bugle instead
he's got a legitimate career path his
intelligence is being used adequately he
really considers himself to have finally
arrived okay so I was originally gonna
do dance Lots amazing spider-man vol 2
but what I decided to do was kind of
wind the clock back a little bit and
instead we're gonna do a video on the
origin of antivenom now the reason why
we're doing this and it's actually kind
of like a fish out of water you know
doing this story but the reason why
we're doing this is because of the fact
that there's a there's like the third
volume I think of dance lots amazing
spider-man called the return of
antivenom and what I didn't want to do
was try to cram the origin in with the
return of antivenom because it's like
hey guys here's the return of a
character that you don't know anything
about and so it's just kind of like well
that's a problem so I figure we go ahead
and just kind of like do the origin but
the cool thing about this is that this
really deals in a lot of ways with the
reshuffling of Eddie Brock and even the
spider-man mythos to a degree it's
really more about Eddie Brock's and
spider-man than Peter Parker but the two
kind of go hand in hand in terms of why
it was done and what I mean is following
the events of one more day when Joe
Quezada sat down and said you know we
need to basically take away everything
that dates Peter Parker that is to say
everything that makes him anything other
than just like a kid trying to find his
way in the world
fans freaked and they they fruit for the
same reason that you know the pre new 52
Wally West disappeared things like that
you know when fans latched on to a
character they don't really like to see
them change but more so than that a lot
of people grew up with like the Peter
Parker Mary Jane Watson relationship and
to suddenly see all that just tossed
away because Peter Parker sold his soul
to the devil so on make could live for
another 10 years really seemed just
weird and people just didn't like that
at all it was one of the most really
reviled spider-man stories in the
history of his characters publication
history if not in the history of comics
in general and so the result was that
spider-man fans and media so on and so
forth everybody just kind of ran J
michael Straczynski off the title and
the result was that the spider-man the
spider-man publications were basically
run by a team of people it was like Joe
Quesada
you know kind of throwing his hands in
the air and saying who wants to write
spider-man everybody was like well I do
and so he was like then all of you guys
come over here and we'll all just write
stories this is where Dan Slott
initially kind of got a start it's
really not until big time that Dan Slott
officially took over the spider-man
title on his own but the fact remains
here that with this whole reshuffling of
the Peter Parker mythos there are a lot
of things that are being introduced a
lot of things that were being done and
that's kind of the beauty the benefit of
this story is yeah it is in the middle
of everything but it's in the middle of
everything before anything's fleshed out
and so a lot of the characters that
we're gonna see popping up here I don't
really have their origin stories
explained you that income you know for
another 10 15 20 issues after this
particular publication but the fact
remains here could that with with with
Peter Parker you know picking up with
him the cool thing is that we kind of
get this you know reminder of everything
that's going on that's what I wanted to
touch on for a second so you know the
whole origin of Peter Parker's timeless
you know a kid who's a science geek
bitten by a radioactive spider gets the
proportional strength of a spider he has
spiders and so on and so forth
spider-man is born it becomes a hero
after the death of Uncle Ben all that
kind of good stuff but the idea and so
there are also some characters that are
being introduced you know you have like
menace for example you have to mister
negative one half of a split personality
between a guy named Martin Lee and we're
really I got posing as Martin Lee and
and mr. negative we have a few
characters who are being introduced here
in there of course you've got your
regular cast so you have like Harry
Osborn so on and so forth but what this
does is it initially picks up with a
conflict between menace and spider-man
now this is one of the things that I was
talking about where we're kind of in the
middle of things but none of this has
really been fleshed out menace is a
character who popped up before this
story happened but the origin of minused
had never really been explored that
didn't happen until amazing spider-man
586 I think and it's ruined out to be
somebody that were quite familiar with
but the idea here is that menace is in a
lot of ways kind of this reimagining of
the Green Goblin right I mean you know
Norman Osborn it's like a like an
intrinsic villain of spider-man
you know Marvel Cinematic Universe is
giving us vulture that's cool
we know it's only a matter of time
before the Green Goblin shows up you
couldn't have spider-man in any film and
not feature the Green Goblin somewhere
along the line that's just people kind
of want a break from all the disastrous
versions of the Green Goblin that we've
gotten from from Sony so far but the
idea here is that menaces really seems
to be acting more like a vigilante you
know in a sense that ministers that
really have an adherence to like one
particular person it's just minutes kind
of pops up and says here are the things
that I'm about you don't about taking
out spider-man so on and so forth but
it's kind of this reminder where things
stand at the same time there are also a
lot of refugees who seem to have been
brought in to the United States for
reasons that we're not really sure about
and they're just kind of escaped being
taking up residence they'll actually
kind of wrap back around towards the end
of the story but again this is just
a reminder of the direction that things
are going in in terms of Peter Parker
where he stands what he's about but this
is all we start to get into the idea of
frontline now prior to this now God by
the name of Dexter Bennett had basically
purchased the Daily Bugle the problem
with this is that instead of upholding
the traditions of J Jonas James sin' by
keeping the Daily Bugle as a reputable
news source albeit a reputable news
source that slanted against spider-man
the fact remains that Dexter Bennett
basically turned it into a tabloid
magazine it was like the National
Enquirer the Weekly World News it was
the the lowest of any form of
publication and because of what because
of that a Peter Parker effectively left
now it was really more like I guess a
firing than him actual actually leaving
and the reason why it was because of the
fact that under you know the the
leadership of Dexter Bennett Peter
Parker was basically transformed into a
member of the paparazzi but his actions
and taking photographs of people albeit
not really wanting to do so led to the
deaths of one of the people that he was
photographing and so following that
realizing that his action was leading to
the death of people he basically vacated
now prior to this Robbie Robertson had
left Sally Floyd being Urich they had
all taken off to form frontline now of
course frontline is an ami guys were
probably familiar with with regards to
Civil War you know initially started out
as a blog but it was transformed into a
wholesale news company now following the
conclusion of civil war and was also
going on here as a frontline itself you
know kind of picking up where Jay jonah
Jameson's daily bugle left off after it
was bought by by Dexter Bennett you know
by considering itself to be a reputable
news source it's not focusing on the
glitz and glamour tabloid stuff and
focusing on actual important stories a
frontline is focusing on a guy by the
name of Randall crown now the reason why
they're focusing on Randall crown is
because he's a mayoral candidate but the
idea here is that he is involved in
these individuals you know the Spider
Man was dealing with those individuals
who were running off in the fight all of
whom appear to have been trafficked into
the United States and so the idea is
that Randall Crown is working with some
third party we don't really know what it
is but he's working with some individual
to traffic humans into the u.s. for
whatever the reason happens to be but
what we end up doing is we basically
pick up with with Norman Osborn's
Thunderbolts now this is when we start
to get into the aftermath of civil war I
mean we've done Secret Invasion right
like we talked about The Secret Invasion
event you can find that down in the
description of this video
but Secret Invasion basically dealt with
the aftermath you know following the
death of Captain America you know
following the Maine Civil War event
itself it was kind of Marvel bringing to
a close this whole idea of the sea
human Registration Act and secret
invasion concluded with Tony Stark being
ousted as director shield and Norman
Osborn taking his place and so because
Norman Osborn took his place Norman
Osborn disbanded shield put hammer in
its place and basically used the
Thunderbolts as a way for him to begin
going through and carry out his own
individual campaigns now I know a lot of
you guys are probably asking about Eddie
Brock why do you guys want to know
what's going on with Eddie Brock and so
what we do is we transition to a place
called feast and feast is basically it
really stands for the idea of a food
emergency aid shelter and training it's
run by the Scott name mr. Lee for the
purpose of grabbing individuals who were
homeless who have been displaced
whatever the case may be and giving them
the tools they need to get back on their
feet and to find success and so what
happened is I guess you basically find
out that Aunt May is volunteering at
this facility but the entire base is
behind this this introduction comes by
way of Betty Brant now of course the
cool thing about Betty Brant if she's a
longtime member of the spider-man matha
she goes back you know a long long long
time and in fact she was the first
romantic interest of Peter Parker before
gwen stacy i don't think it was really
short-lived it was really more of you
know Marvel kind of kind of toying
around with the idea before gwen stacy
and peter got together but she's here
because of the fact that dexter bennett
basically says look I'm a supporter of
Randall Crown alright this newspaper is
basically going to serve as the media
arm of Randall crown we're gonna do
everything we can to get him elected if
there's a publication out there that's
posting information they basically
contradicts the idea that Randall crown
is the best candidate then your job
Betty Brant is to go find information to
discredit those individuals in this
instance bill Hollister bill Hollister
is a guy who's basically running against
Randall Crown and what Dexter Bennett
says is go find a guy named Martin Lee
he's basically helping to fund the
campaign of Bill Hollister your job is
to report on him and to find dirt on
that guy so we can use that to discredit
bill Hollister we can say you know what
Bill Hollister is being funded by a
criminal he's being funded by a guy
who's involved into having you whatever
the case may be find information so that
we can use it to discredit Hollister so
with Betty Brant showing up here at the
at the feast facility this is when we
pick up with Eddie Brock now the reason
why I kind of waited until this point to
talk about this guy know a lot of you
guys are kind of like there is a lot
there was a lot going on with Eddie
Brock yes there was um Sally comic
popping myself actually had this really
cool conversation I call him to ask him
some questions about Eddie Brock because
there were a few things that I was I was
curious about because I didn't really
know how we got from a
I mean I knew Eddie Brock was venom he
was one of spider-man's most vulnerable
villains they were on-again off-again
allies you know Eddie Brock had his own
moral code but I didn't know how he got
from Eddie Brock being venom to Eddie
Brock basically being a cancer patient
and so when I was talking to sound like
comic pop he had a really good saber
where he basically said that following
the events of one more day Marvel looked
at Eddie Brock is like this holdover
from the 1990s that it wasn't really
relevant anymore so what Marvel wanted
to do was reshuffle the venom concept
around and see if they could shop it
around in different characters and then
finally find one that they could set on
and so what they did is they basically
passed the Venom symbiote from Eddie
Brock to Mac Gargan also known as
scorpion and that's the reason why if
you guys see venom as part of
Thunderbolts which you will see here
that's scorpion that's not actually
Eddie Brock that's why you're seeing you
know really Eddie and venom in two
different locations but the idea here is
that for the character of Eddie Marvell
did a lot of changing with regards to
his origin with regards to his backstory
and him suffering from cancer was the
way in which they transition things what
Marvel did is with us I think was
spectacular spider-man vol 2 the first
five issues composed a story called the
hunger and what it basically said is
where the original introduction of venom
established that that Eddie Brock was a
guy whose career was basically ruined by
Peter Parker by spider-man and he bonded
with the Venom symbiote for retribution
what Marvel does is they came back and
said no that's not really the case
instead what happened was Eddie Brock
had cancer and the Venom symbiote bonded
itself to Eddie Brock just for the
simple fact that Eddie Brock's body was
just pumping out chemicals like crazy
and it would keep the Venom symbiote
going and so in response to that every
time Eddie Brock went after spider-man
every time the two of them got into a
conflict Eddie Brock was acting on the
defensive he was terrified that if
spider-man took the Venom symbiote away
from him it would result in him dying
now eventually what Marvel did is they
came back between 2004 and 2007 and they
started launching all these small little
stories about Eddie Brock for about two
or three of them and what happened is
Eddie Brock basically cast off the
symbiote and itself he came to terms
with the idea that he was going to die
and this basically picked up with him
succumbing to his cancer at least a
period has to come to his cancer and
falling into the process of dying now
again this ties into the idea that
Marvel was moving the Venom symbiote
away from Eddie and putting it on on
scorpion but what happens is Eddie Brock
basically travels to the feast facility
he meets with mr. Lee and mr. Lee
basically cures him now this is
the other half of the mr. negative
personas one of the reasons why I kind
of wanted to wait to this point to cover
that but the whole mr. negative mr. Li
dichotomy is kind of strange that's
fleshed out in a different origin we
don't really do know too much about him
not for this story anyway the only thing
we really need to know is that mr. Li
the actual person that we're seeing here
is a guy that can heal people by
touching them when it comes to mr.
negative he's the other side of the coin
it's like this dichotomy between good
and evil Bruce Banner The Incredible
Hulk that kind of thing you notices dr.
Jekyll mr. Hyde sort of situation the
face that we see here with mr. Lee is
the good side but at this point the way
that Marvel's played this out he doesn't
know about the mr. negative persona he
just kind of switches over to it and
then mr. negative basically operates as
a crime boss in Chinatown but what
happens is that where mr. Lee had
essentially touched Eddie Brock and
cured him of his cancer in this instance
when mr. Lee's talking to Betty Brant
and he's basically talking about how
this place is considered to be a place
of miracles but how it's really you know
God curing people so on and so forth
when he touches Eddie Brock a second
time it reactivates the latent symbian
venom symbian in his body now what this
does is this basically sets the stage
for the introduction of anti-venom for
the idea of Eddie Brock going from
normal Eddie Brock to becoming
anti-venom and the way this is done is
actually really really cool it's one of
these interesting things worse like a
million different things all going on at
the same time but with Peter Parker
heading back you know going back to his
residence he's encountered by Norman
Osborn now the reason why is because at
this moment right now spider-man's
essentially a fugitive and the reason
why spider-man's a fugitive is because
Norman Osborn with all his power all his
ability has been trying to find a way to
bring spider-man down the problem with
this is that spider-man is an Avenger
spider-man is one of the world's most
celebrated heroes the other thing you
have to keep in mind here is that
following the events of one more day and
I think during the events of brand-new
day I'm not gonna swear to that Peter
Parker went to dr. strange and had dr.
strange White's the world's mind that
Peter Parker was spider-man of course he
revealed his identity during civil war
that's why no one knows who he is
because Doctor Strange took care of that
for him and so the result is that Norman
Osborn all he really knows is that Peter
Parker gets pictures of spider-man the
two of them seemed to work together and
he wants to know where spider-man is
that's why spider-man's being framed
because Norman Osborn basically wants to
make spider-man look like a murderer by
going around killing people and then
putting spider on you know spider
tracker devices on these dead bodies so
anybody who covers a story any forensic
you know scientist whoever it is and
analyzes these bodies will come to the
conclusion that spider-man killed them
now of course we know Spiderman didn't
but what this does is it allows Norman
Osborn to kind of you know show up in in
New York show up in Manhattan and begin
the process of trying to find Peter
Parker
now with Norman Osborn basically being
forced to vacate the apartment because
of the fact that you know the the
roommate of Peter Parker who at the time
was a cop was basically showing up
because of the fact that Norman Osborn
didn't want to be seen as somebody who
was who was you know caught abusing his
power because likely it would lead to
him being removed as director of shield
who ended up happening here is he
basically takes off and then Peter
Parker is spider-man goes to see him and
his base of operations more or less to
to question him to interrogate him to
find out what it is he's doing because
keep in mind while Norman Osborn doesn't
know that Peter Parker spider-man Peter
Parker knows that Norman Osborn is the
Green Goblin
and where Norman Osborn is putting on
the front that he's a legit guy where
he's putting on the front of the world
that he's a capable director of shield
or I guess the director of Hammer at
this point Peter Parker knows it's only
a matter of time before his you know
nefarious deeds come to light and so
Peter Parker's half waiting it out half
looking for information to verify that
Norman Osborn's a bad guy because of
course you know we know that he is but
what Norman Osborn had also done is in
response to the idea that he had to
leave Peter Parker's apartment early he
said the rest of his Thunderbolts out
songbird venom so on and so forth sent
them all out and basically said go find
spider-man do whatever you need to do
but go find spider-man of course not
realizing the spider-man was going to
show up on its doorstep but what
happened is the Venom symbiote was
basically tracking down its previous
host you know tracking down the last
host that it had the issue with this is
that wanting to keep him on the venom
Cindy it has a mind of its own in a lot
of ways not only that you know Matt
garden doesn't really know how to use it
effectively he's still relatively new to
the whole venom concept and so he's not
nearly as a debt or as used to venom as
as Eddie Brock is and the result is at
the Venom symbiote is actually tracking
down or at least it seems like it's
tracking down Eddie Brock and the reason
why is because what it does is it
smashes into the feast facility and
encounters Eddie Brock with the
intention of reemerging with him the
issue with this is that when the Venom
symbiote accesses his body it
jump-starts this latent you know
symbiote these semi up cells inside the
body of Eddie Brock and what he does is
he emerges as anti-venom now with
regards to Marvel creating this this
stay
they had to find a way to differentiate
the two right I mean of all the
symbionts have some aspect of them that
make you them make them unique whether
it's toxin basically the child of
carnage whether it is you know venom
itself whether it is carnage itself
whatever the case may be a lot of the
symbiotes have things that make them
different than make them unique they
share a lot of common traits the
immunity is spider-man's spider-sense
you know the the same sort of abilities
the spider-man has wall-crawling
shooting webs so on and so forth for
anti-venom he's basically a guy or at
least the power is that that anti-venom
has are almost like a like a Healing
Touch so to speak in the sense that you
know the abilities of Martin Lee were
absorbed to some capacity or incent for
more fashion but what anti-venom has the
ability to do is to basically touch the
bodies of other people and cleanse them
of impurities and what this does is it
gives venema weakness to anti-venom in
the form that whenever Eddie Brock
touches the Venom symbiote the Venom
symbiote will start to recoil it'll
start to sort of go away because of the
fact that it's literally being burned
it's like putting fire to your skin and
so what happens the spider-man of course
shows up on the scene realizing that the
vent you know that Venom's basically
shown up at the feast facility where
Aunt May works and it's just like this
three-way battle between the two and
it's actually really kind of cool to see
it's like spider-man versus anti-venom
vs. venom and it's awesome I love I love
things like this I love the way these
events you know kind of kind of coalesce
the way these little stories coalescent
and begin to come together but in the
midst of this whole conflict in the
midst of all this madness we suddenly
have the Menace arriving now of course
what the minute showing up here it's
really for the purpose of grabbing Bill
Hollister carry out his own goals
carrying out its own means that's what
we do is well you know menace basically
takes off with Bill Hollister or at
least it seems like menaces taking off
with Bill Hollister we have Spider Man
you know Peter Parker of course planting
his camera for the purpose of taking
pictures so we can give them to your
front line and then engaging in the
conflict the funny thing about this is
this kind of like a mistake of identity
right I mean Peter Parker comes to
realize that anti-venom is Eddie Brock
but in his mind Eddie Brock is a bad guy
you know if Eddie Brock is wearing a
symbian did it means any Brock's gonna
go do bad stuff and this is a huge deal
because yeah Cletus Kasady was dangerous
you know but Eddie Brock knows how to
fight smarter man in a way Karnas may
never know now of course they're both
equally dangerous and in truth I would
go as far as to say that if if we're
talking about a direct fight Peter
Parker going against carnage Peter
Parker going or going against venom it
might be kind of a tough sell to tell me
that
I might get the upper hand that in the
end carnage would be probably the one to
come out on top but the idea here is a
Peter Parker basically says look you
know if you're Eddie Brock then you must
be a bad guy but you're fighting venom
so are you a bad guy is Peter Parker
trying to get his bearings trying to
understand what's going on but while
this is happening kind of staying out of
the way at the same time and so a really
funny moment ends up happening here you
know when Peter Parker takes this
philosophy the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
when he tells you no and even it means
like hey you hate venom right and I was
like yeah he's like well I hate him too
let's team up and then they basically
team up against venom and and start
taking him out and it's really cool to
see it's it's really fun to see but the
issue with this is that you know when
when that garden is basically cured or
at least it seems like he's cured of
this Venom symbiote where's basically
removed from his body anti-venom
basically turns his sights to out to
Peter Parker now the funny thing about
this is he says look I can sense that
you that you have issues that your your
blood is not as pure as it needs to be
part of this is because of the fact that
at some point along the line you were
exposed to radioactive man so you've got
a little bit of radiation in your blood
but then he also realizes oh you've got
a lot of radiation in your blood now we
know the desktop Peter Parker's powers
function you know Peter Parker has his
abilities because his blood is
irradiated and so if anti-venom were to
be able to go through with what it is
he's doing right now which is basically
purging the radiation from the blood of
Peter Parker he would lose all of his
spider powers and so it's kind of cool
seeing this whole thing go on the
problem with this is that while all
these events are unfolding of course
when the cops had shown up when Menace
was trying to take Bill Hollister and at
Menace was forced to leave Bill
Hollister behind that ministers across
Norman Osborn now this is cool because
this is kind of this return to
familiarity with Norman Osborn right
like there are moments in his characters
publication history that are iconic for
example the death of the Green Goblin
when when Harry Hellmuth said when Harry
Potter when Norman Osborn and Peter
Parker fought following the night Gwen
Stacy died that it resulted in really an
in Norman Osborn falling on his own
sword you know being impaled by his own
glider in a lot of ways this bear some
hallmarks to that particular fight in
the sense that menaces using the various
devices of Norman Osborn
menaces facing off against him and the
fights very similar to the conflict
between the two and even menacing Minnis
itself references the instance where
Norman Osborn basically died against
Peter Parker is as they look
you are impaled on your own glider
before
see if we can do it again now in the
middle of this whole conflict with you
know between Peter Parker and anti-venom
the forces of the Thunderbolts arrived
on the scene and the reason why is
because of the fact that Norman Osborn's
like look guys we gotta go and we gotta
bail the authorities are moving in here
we're making too much of a scene we're
supposed to be operating behind the
scenes no one's supposed to know that my
hand is here no one supposed to catch my
hand in the cookie jar so he says in
order to keep that from happening
we got to bail out so he says prob Mac
Gargan we'll get him out of here you
know and of course the idea is grab
Peter Parker or EV spider-man if he can
as well of course they're not able to
and Peter Parker essentially makes his
escape at the same time it's Marvel
setting the stage for the the whole
events though the whole situation with
the future of anti-venom and the citizen
and even have kind of sits down for
second ahsoka spiderman took off i can
go after spider-man or i can go after
venom what anti-venom says is I'm going
to pursue venom my goal is going to be
to take him out and remove the last
vestiges of the Venom symbiote those
little cells or what-have-you
from the body of scorpion basically
removing his ability to become venom and
so because of this with everything kind
of wrapping up you know Peter Parker
travels back checks on his on main make
sure that everything is all right but
then we also have Norman Osborn speaking
directly to to Randle crown and what we
find out is that Norman Osborn and
Randall kromm were essentially working
together in the sense that Randall crown
was was trafficking people into the u.s.
by way of the various you know cargo
ships and so on and so forth that
belonged to Norman Osborn of course this
was really you know kind of a big deal
is a very hush-hush thing for Osborn
just because of the fact that if it came
to light that he was complicit in the
trafficking of humans it would bring
down everything that he's worked so hard
for because remember what Norman
Osborn's trying to do is basically take
over the United States you know we've
talked by that before we haven't really
covered Dark Reign directly but that was
the whole basis of Dark Reign was him
trying to take over the United States
the Dark Avengers the doct x-men so on
and so forth it was him trying to
conquer everything and so what he does
is he grabs the camera that Peter Parker
had basically left behind you know
forgetting that it was there and he
starts showing the photos to the members
of the Thunder Bulls and he says there's
a weakness here there's a weakness here
that we can exploit and what he does is
he says whenever this this cameras
posted up it's basically whoever the
whoever spider-man is getting pictures
for himself and what he says is that
inside the suit on the spider is
basically a tracking device and the
camera follows the spider suit which is
how it is that it's always able to get
these perfect shots that's why
the cameras just not taking shots of an
empty road you know it is it's actually
following his physical body and that's
why he's always got his chest or a suit
turned out to the camera so we can take
pictures of him while he's moving
but what Norman Osborn says is what we
can do is we base we can basically tap
into the frequency that this camera uses
to follow the device in his chest and we
can in turn find a way to basically
infiltrate spider-man's spider-sense to
basically deceive it so he doesn't know
that we're there we can use that at you
know to our own advantage and then we
can take him out from close quarters
from a distance we can shoot him while
he's going from building to building and
his spider sense will not alert him to
what it is it's about to happen now from
here we find out that among the various
soldiers that exist as part of Norman
Osborn's regime is actually anti-venom
is Eddie Brock and this is when we
learned that his suit basically allows
him to shape-shift it allows him to take
on virtually any form that he wants to
and the result is that he's essentially
infiltrating this so the cool thing is
that again Eddie Brock is anti-venom
you know it's kind of like a it's trying
to be a hero he's trying to be a good
guy and that's one of the things that
makes him so unique the problem with
this is that after this story I don't
think he shows up again until the return
of anti-venom
so it's kind of sad to see him only show
up for a handful of comics but the idea
here is that he's essentially keeping
tabs on everything that's going on
monitoring everything that's taking
place now with regards to Matt Gargan
with regards to scorpion basically
losing his ability to become venom it's
not like the venom Samiha it's gone from
his body in its entirety it's still
there the issue is that it's basically
been damaged to the point that it almost
seems to be beyond repair and so what
happens is radioactive man basically
begins to expose the body of Matt gargon
to radioactivity and the reason why is
because the goal is to basically take a
blood sample and see if there's a way to
essentially remove the antibodies
basically that anti-venom puts out to
remove those from the body of Matt
Gargan and so what happens is Norman
Osborn actually takes these chemicals
and uses them on a guy named freak now
freak was originally introduced as a
drug addict in the amazing spider-man
story that's really all he was he's a
character that was created as a means to
an end and what I mean by that is he
appeared in a couple stories here and
there but this is by far the most
notable role he played the Freak was
basically a guy who grabbed just a
random syringe injected himself with the
chemicals from Curt Conners from a
lizard's lab and then suddenly he
developed the ability to basically adapt
to any situation he's not you know he's
not like I'm a mutant or anything and
it's not an instantaneous thing instead
what
happens is you know he'll be burned
alive for example and then his body into
a chrysalis stage and he'll come out
immune to fire and that's the way his
body functions he gets to the point
where he just basically is immortal like
he can't be killed and that's what
Norman Osborn's making on here what he
does is he takes the anti-venom compound
of the anti-venom compound he injects it
into the body of freak with the
intention of creating this super venom
and the purpose of having the super
venom will basically be to kind of lay
waste to things and that's the danger of
it is that a few drops will ultimately
end up killing people and so what
happens is Norman Osborn basically goes
back to his lab for the purpose of using
this chemical to engineer it modify it a
bit and then jumpstart the powers of of
Mac Gargan allowing him to become venom
again the funny thing about this though
is this is kind of like this resurgence
of the Green Goblin not perfectly not in
the sense that like the Green Goblin has
been gone forever the green Goblin's
been around but this is just another
instance where he shows up it's another
instance of this sort of split situation
in the mind in the body of of of Norman
Osborn now from here it's also you know
again bull's eye and the various members
of the Thunderbolts carrying out the
mission of Norman Osborn basically
finding Peter Parker because you're at
least finding spider-man because again
they're basically using the the
frequencies of the camera uses to to
access his device in his chest to tap
into his location to basically use it
like a homing device and that's exactly
what they do you have bullseye you have
a handful of soldiers that locate
spider-man and track him down the
problem with this is that in the midst
of their efforts to take out spider-man
the entire group is suddenly met with
the arrival of anti-venom this is cool
because anti-venom basically takes all
these guys out and it's interesting to
see these two guys pair up because it
turns into an actual team-up but it
starts is like a weird situation that's
part of man just doesn't really know how
to work his mind around I mean he's used
to Eddie Brock being a bad guy he's used
to Eddie Brock only working alongside
him in certain situations for example
the emergence of carnage and so because
of that the two of them actually working
alongside you know working side-by-side
as heroes the idea of of antivenom
saying hey look you left your camera
behind they took it and that's how they
found you you know it's interesting as
it's sort of a weird situation for a
Peter Parker and so ultimately what
happens is anti-venom and Parker are
able to basically take out these various
soldiers knock out bullseye and then
just bail out now of course we also have
Mac Gargan being injected with the serum
the issue is that it's not an
instantaneous thing it'll take time for
the venom stim yet to come back and the
reason why is because the purpose of
this
is to basically burn out the anti-venom
antibodies and allow the Venom symbiote
to begin reimbursing and so while it's
in the process of doing that scorpion is
basically given an updated scorpion suit
and so again this is Marvel kind of 20
this is Marvel going back and forth
saying hey guys you know you're getting
the best of both you're basically
getting a side-by-side comparison here's
a story where you see the scorpion and
you see the scorpion as venom in the
exact same situations the exact same
conflicts which one do you like more is
really kind of what was going on here
and so the result is that we you know we
really get a kind of choose which one we
enjoy which one we don't enjoy and so
picking up with spider-man and picking
up with anti-venom the idea here is
anti-venom basically says hey look
Norman Osborn the Thunderbolts the guys
are looking for they all went back to
the Osborn lab they're all back there
you need to go to the Osborn research
group if you want to track him down as
it was kind of cool seeing these two
guys work together but we also see some
really cool bit of ingenuity the reason
why this works so well and the reason
why team-ups between venom and
spider-man have always worked is because
it's like they're two sides of the same
coin
you've got spider-man with the spider
sense you know with his capabilities his
agility strength so on and so forth and
you've got Eddie Brock with his
experience as part of venom you know
with the Venom symbiote and so because
of that we basically have you know what
looks like spider-man infiltrating the
facility and being attacked by the
thunderbolts only for us to find out
that's not spider-man that's actually
anti-venom shape-shifted as spider-man
and so it's cool to see these these
things go against each other it's cool
to see them functioning so what happens
is of course you know Green Goblin makes
his presence known he and spider-man
fight for a little while it's kind of
wrapping these things up by giving us a
bit of fanservice in terms of the the
characters you know fighting against one
another but we also find out that a lot
of these people that have been brought
in a lot of these humans that have been
trafficked dead I mean kidnapped we're
being experimented on and so the
question is okay you know where's this
road going to lead now we're actually
not gonna find that out we're not gonna
find out here where this road leads
instead what we do is we basically pick
up with with scorpion you know again
continuing to fight against uh against
anti-venom and then actually injecting
him with a barb that basically seems to
take away Eddie Brock's ability to be
venom instead following this we have Mac
Gargan just we you know rien voguing
this venom simian after it's finally
healed and re-emerging is sort of going
forward with the assumption that
anti-venom is basically defeated that he
can't come back from this and so during
the entirety of this conflict norman
osborn had essentially activated a
self-destruct in the building with the
idea that the entire building was gonna
come crashing down that everybody was
gonna be killed spider-man was gonna die
you know of course freak so on that
building was
we know they made it out but in the end
is this idea that we're kind of left
with a few unanswered questions in the
sense of these individuals who are being
experimented on so on and so forth but
we're also left with the idea of
antivenom you know kind of focusing on
Eddie Brock himself in the end he just
sort of says hey look you know life gave
me a second chance life gave me the
opportunity to go forward and be a hero
the question is what am I gonna do with
this heroic role okay so picking up with
the amazing spider-man again and picking
up with like the main Amazing Spiderman
now that we've kind of done the origin
of antivenom this is really kind of cool
I mean again you know in the last video
we talked about how after the events of
one more day that the spider-man title
just kind of turned into like a
committee based publication in the sense
there was a group of people writing it
and we had also talked about how there
were a few changes that were being
fleshed out here and there in terms of
when Dan Slott officially took over as
the sole writer of the title with
spider-man big time but we were talking
about how Dan Slott was basically
getting rid of a lot of the things that
he didn't like you know about the the
whole committee writing everything how
he basically wanted to kind of clear the
landscape and make the spider-man title
all his own and that's usually what
happens you know when it comes to a
writer taking over a publication they'll
go about it in different ways some
writers will just kind of build on
what's already there other writers will
wipe the slate clean and start over
again a really good example is like
black panther you know for example when
it came to the mythos so the character
as he was created Christopher priest had
like the landmark run in vol 3 that
basically introduced all kinds of new
concepts expanded on the Black Panther
mythos instead of wiping all that clean
during the events of Avengers of New
Avengers Jonathan Hickman built on that
and then added something called the
necropolis which is where Black Panther
communicates with the dead with the
Black Panthers of the past those
individuals that have held the title
before him and died of old age or just
died in combat or whatever the case may
be and then right now with with a
Tallahassee who's writing the story of
Black Panther he's building on top of
all of that and adding his own stuff
into it so different writers take things
different way so it was Dan Slott he
looked around at the spider-man mythos
and he said okay so here's where we
stand
following the events of one more day
Marvel had basically come along they had
a flash Thompson as part of the US Army
he basically fell into a coma due to
some injuries when he woke up he had
basically forgotten a lot of the
conflict and a lot of the strife that he
had put Peter Parker through when they
were in high school so it was kind of a
way to reinvigorate the character of
Flash Thompson and they went forward his
friends this allowed for Marvel to
basically spin Flash Thompson now so he
would
become agent venom with I think that
that first story arc began in spotting
the amazing spider-man and this volume
actually and as a backup feature in this
particular story with amazing spider-man
653 or 654 or something like that and
then they turn around they said okay so
Mary Jane Watson part of one more day
Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson were
married four years after one more day
that basically wrecked Condit so the two
of them never got married that when they
were supposed to get married Peter
Parker's you know adventures of
spider-man resulted in him missing his
wedding day and so while Mary Jane
Watson as part of spider-man big time
right now still knows his identity
instead of ever having been married
they've dated you know very passionately
for a while and they're just friends at
this point in time it was adding in
things like Aunt May getting married to
Jay jonah Jameson's father the
introduction of Carly Cooper as the
girlfriend of Peter Parker it was just
kind of structuring things shifting
things moving things around in a way
that dance Locke you kind of look at
this landscape and say okay what do we
want to keep and what do we want to get
rid of and so that's what a lot of this
does spider-man big time for the first
you know a few volumes really going up
to like Spider Island began the process
of getting rid of a lot of things that
Dan Slott didn't like but it was also
the idea of building up to superior
spider-man the idea that Doctor Octopus
would take over the body of Peter Parker
now what this does is that's kind of a
long you know exposition in terms of
terms of getting into the story but what
this does and the reason why I wanted to
call it up go ahead and make those
points it's because we really kind of
pick up with Peter Parker in his off
time and this is why a lot of spider-man
fans loved Peter Parker a spider-man
that's why they loved his stories
because you would see just as many you
know volumes just as many story arcs
they dealt with him being spider-man
fighting bad guys teaming up with the
Avengers Fantastic Four and so on as you
would Peter Parker in his off time what
he's doing when he's not spider-man it
was this well-rounded well fleshed out
life of Peter Parker within Marvel
Comics
which is why he's like this timeless
character you know Peter Parker will
never go away he's like Batman he's like
Superman you know he'll be known from
now until really until humanity
collapses in its entirety but the cool
thing about this is this does kind of
harken back to the idea of Mary Jane and
that's why I wanted to throw that in
there because of course a Peter Parker
cheering on Carly Cooper you know
telling her yeah you're doing a great
great job as she's you know doing her
roller derby thing Mary Jane kind of
makes these comments about how you know
Peter Parker really got his life
together you know he was able to balance
his life is Peter Parker and his life is
spider-man but he did it without Mary
Jane now again this is Dan Slott kind of
reaffirming to the reader that the two
of them are not
together and they've never been married
because remember when spider-man Big
Time was announced when mama came along
and they were like hey guys
spider-man big time it was like all-new
all-different marvel for amazing
spider-man in the sense that it was like
hey guys like this is the place to start
if you guys really want to get into
spider-man start now with spider-man big
time and even a lot of people who were
spider-man fans you go on the Marvel
subreddit really go there anymore but if
you go to like that
spider-man subreddit there'll be a lot
of people who will say like spider-man
Big Time is a is a good place to jump
off from if you want to get started they
you know tell you to read Wikipedia
articles or something like that or watch
my videos if you want to want to get a
good idea of what to know if you're
gonna jump into it but that's this is
kind of you know designed to be a great
jumping-off point for for the amazing
spider-man so this is the reason why
because it's Dan Slott kind of showing
us you know where things are where they
stand now at this point we transition
over to Andrews Air Force Base and the
reason why is because the son of j jonah
jameson is actually getting ready to go
on a mission into space the issue with
this is that this segment sees the
return of Alastair Smythe which I think
it's Smythe or might be Smith I don't
how you how you want to pronounce it but
Alastair Smythe is the son of Spencer
Smythe the Spencer Smythe was a longtime
villain of spider-man are really even
Jay jonah Jameson but the issue was he
was defeated in almost every turn
eventually this led to his death and the
result was that Alastair Smythe
basically picked up the mantle of Spider
Slayer but much like his father Alastair
basically uses cybernetic enhancements
to his advantage in the form of robots
that are made or people who have
existing sava netic enhancements by by
improving them and then had like
rallying them to his cause so it's kind
of like this reimagining of the sinister
six to a degree that's not led by Doctor
Octopus not the exact same but that's
about the closest I can get in terms of
offering a comparison but cloud of
stares Smith his entire campaign here is
really to just bring down everything
that J jonah Jameson cares about in the
reason why is because he blames j jonah
jameson for the death of his father now
the issue here is that of course with
spider-man being here we also have max
Modell now max Modell doesn't seem like
you would be an important thing but it's
huge and the reason why is because he's
one of the smartest people in the Marvel
Universe and the way that Dan slots
gonna do this is actually really cool
the way that he pulls this off but again
this is really them just kind of
analyzing the vessel you know going over
the ship so on and so forth you know
looking at everything and we basically
had a lot really telling us how it's all
supposed to function you know her eyes
Labs is behind this project too some of
the best engineers in the world so on
and so forth
you know it's expected to go off without
a hitch but transitioning back to two
Peter Parker this is kind of the cool
thing here because when he's hanging out
with Carly Cooper keep in mind Carly
does not know that he's spider-man she
just knows that he's Peter Parker Mary
Jane Watson again does know that he's
spider-man and so the funny thing is
that when Peters hanging out with Carly
Cooper he has to put on this show that
he doesn't know how to roller-skate he
doesn't know how to do any of that stuff
and it's a great bonding chance because
that's really all it is it's a great
bonding experience for the two of them
you know the two of them just really
kind of having fun that sort of thing
but of course once she goes to get
changed in order to you know for them to
hang out Peter Parker is like I'm
amazing when it comes to roller-skate of
course is his enhanced agility his
balance so on and so forth makes them
exceptional at this but the other cool
thing as a dance lot kind of begins to
wrap up this loose in and not really a
loose in but they get to kind of wrap
things up with Mary Jane Watson none of
the sense that she's gonna be out of the
picture forever but in the sense of
telling us as the reader here's how the
two view each other of course is a
conversation between the two of them you
know Mary Jane kind of saying you know
look you really care it looks like you
really care about Carly Cooper are you
gonna tell her your secret that kind of
thing and the reason why Mary Jane
Watson is doing this is because again
according to the new history between
Peter and Mary you know she just didn't
really like the idea of him functioning
as the amazing spider-man and Peter
Parker at the same time the reason being
because if they actually ended up
getting married because they toyed with
that for a while
with the idea that they would actually
go on to get married where you know they
had missed their first wedding date but
if the two of them actually did get
married his his actions as spider-man
would put their child in jeopardy
now this is one of the reasons why
spider-man renew your vows was written
during seeker Wars because it was
basically Marvel coming back and saying
well what if in this particular story
arc you know Mary Jane Watson and Peter
Parker didn't take that route what if
instead they actually got married and
they had a child you know what if one
more day never took place what would
that universe look like what would that
world look like now of course we saw how
all that unfolded and we're actually
seeing it now with regards to the
relaunch of renew your vows is gonna be
kind of focusing on this Mary Jane
Watson Peter Parker you know that sort
of situation but the idea here is that
as a sort of leave Peter's left with
this idea of hey maybe I should tell her
maybe I should you know let her in on
the secret that I have in terms of my
identity the kicker to all this and
there's a problem with all this is that
Peter Parker is basically recalled to
the Air Force Base and the reason why is
because you know it's Peter Parker one
of the smartest people that's working at
horizon
not only that because of his
intelligence because some of the things
that he had achieved when we talked
about I guess in the last video we had
talked about horizon labs he's kind of
drawn this special eye of match mode
Allen the sense of Max Modell doesn't
really look at him as like a cut above
the rest but sees a lot of potential in
Peter Parker as Peter Parker being one
of the smartest people that will ever
exist in the Marvel Universe now that
doesn't mean max Modell is like yeah man
Peter Parker's the next Reed Richards
but he's certainly wildly capable in
terms of his of his knowledge and so
because of that he's kind of brought on
in an advisory capacity to make sure
that all the all the the the t's have
been crossed all the eyes have been
dotted and that kind of thing but the
problem with this is that as
spider-sense kicks in and he basically
has to race off you don't leave you
Maximo Dell on his own now of course
this is when we learned that Alastair
Smith has a much larger plan here in the
sense that where he brings in his
various villains of course you know
within this Andrews Air Force Base you
know in the control tower he has all his
own minions so on and so forth he has a
multitude of these little small bugs and
different things like that but it's
designed for the purpose of wreaking
absolute havoc and so where these
different forces jump in it's really
kind of like Peter Parker facing off
against all these guys as best they can
the problem with this is that Jay jonah
Jameson says hey look man you cannot
face off against all these villains on
your own one because there's just too
many of them and two because my son's on
that ship and that ship may crash it may
blow up who knows what's going to happen
with it and so ultimately Peter Parker
says that needs to be the main emphasis
that needs to be the main focus going to
that vessel to make sure that nothing
you know nothing erroneous takes place
here the problem is that once he gets on
board he's met with Mac Gargan now I was
holding off until this part of the story
to basically get into this idea of venom
but I imagine a lot of you guys watching
this watching you know the video on
antivenom might have had some questions
about what happens to the actual venom
Symbian when it comes to the character
of scorpion because right now he doesn't
have the venom sibian so here's the deal
between the time that Joe Quesada took
over Marvel I guess took over the
position of editor-in-chief and Marvel
really leading up to the time that he
left which i think was around 2011 2012
again it was really Marvel just trying
everything because remember they were
coming out of the comic bust of the 90s
so it was just like write it print it
you know if it's fictional key but if it
doesn't work cancel it and that was
really the way they function in a lot of
different ways but it was also casada
looking at the Marvel landscape and
saying let's change things up let's look
at things that historically haven't
worked and let's get rid of those let's
reduce the mutant population because
there's just too many of them right now
let's focus on a core group of mutants
let's do great storytelling instead of
just having
I swear some mutant shows up with some
powers and they're never seen or heard
from again it was a lot of small things
like that and so this sort of a
reinvigoration project you know again
stretched over the course of a decade
and it was just something being tried
and then if it didn't work an event
would come along that would basically
wipe that away with the character of Mac
Gargan and the Venom symbiote that all
really seemed to take place during siege
and what I mean here is that Mac Gargan
the scorpion couldn't be venom forever
who was literally Marvel just throwing
the Venom symbiote on different people
in fact during the events of siege
there's a there's a section where Carol
Danvers Captain Marvel becomes venom for
a really short amount of time but the
idea was to basically look around and to
say where can we move this to now of
course Flash Thompson had been really
popular for quite some time and that was
the reason why Marvel basically went in
the direction of taking the the concept
of the Venom symbiote and applying it to
Flash Thompson sending him forward as
agent venom it was basically the US
military taking the Soviet away from
scorpion and throwing it on flash that's
why we're at this point right now where
scorpion is not venom now transitioning
back to the story there's actually
there's actually a pretty funny moment
when spider-man is again on this on this
ship fighting against a scorpion at the
same time you have Alastair Smith and
his various minions chasing after Jay
jonah jameson trying to take him out and
spider-man actually caused avengers
match and the problem is that the person
that he gets it's squirrel girl and it's
hilarious because he was like hey put
someone else anyone else on I don't care
who it is just not you but it's kind of
funny because like swore girls never
lost a fight she's defeated everybody
she made Galactus a friend you know but
she defeated Thanos she's defeated
everybody that she's fought against she
defeated Doctor Doom she's really kind
of like the one person you would want on
your side and that's sort of the irony
about this right you know it's the one
character that's been best defeated
everyone but that no one takes seriously
as it was kind of cool you know to see
this little bit of a thing tacked in
there this is this little banter back
and forth between the two of them you
know where spider-man is freaking yeah
you know he was like I'm literally on a
ship fighting you know like I'm gonna
run out of oxygen soon if you do not
help me out and he just kind of cuts her
off and she's like there's always time
for manners and that sort of thing but
in the end he basically just kind of
hangs up in the man in the middle of the
call and and basically walks away now
from here we transition over to Doctor
Octopus and again this is where Dan
Slott was building everything up because
in all these stories we didn't really
know what the grand plan of Doctor
Octopus was we didn't really know where
this was going
all we knew was that Doctor Octopus
would just show up periodically and have
some plan and that's why the whole
superior spider-man
so well because instead of it being you
know suddenly doctor octopus's in a
comic and then three issues later he's
Peter Parker like it wasn't like that I
said it was like this gradual build over
the course of some you know twenty
volumes or fifteen volumes that led up
to this moment where he becomes superior
spider-man so it was a really cool slow
build and in my mind those are always
the best ones the ones that build up
slowly that lead to this really really
cool situation that allows us to kind of
go forward with the status quo being
changed but the issue here is of course
for the most part the Doctor Octopus
looks at this and says you know I need I
need horizon labs mission to be
successful for whatever my grand plan
happens to be but with Alastair Smythe
his forces had essentially screwed up
the control systems of the shuttle and
so Doctor Octopus basically fixes them
it allows the shuttle to basically just
kind of take off the way that is
supposed to and with spider-man in
freefall he's rescued by Carol Danvers
now this is when we have the
introduction of the rest of the New
Avengers alongside a few members of the
Fantastic Four I think it's really only
been Grimm
now that I think about it but it's kind
of cool to see this team-up because for
a story like this Dan Slott played it
pretty smart I mean something like
spider-slayer you know how is there
Smith we don't need like the full
contingent of the Avengers and the full
contingent of the Fantastic Four and the
x-men we don't need that that'd be
overkill in the extreme it's always cool
to see them team up but there has to be
some measure of practicality when you're
writing a story especially when it comes
to spider-man because in a lot of ways
as capable as he is he's very much a
street-level hero in the sense that
he'll go off and save the world
but nine times out of ten his own
personal stories see him dealing with
things on the ground level there aren't
very many you know at least knowing now
anyway I wouldn't say they're very nice
spider-man stories where he's off like
fighting in space different things like
that you see those from time to time and
they cross levers but this story is
usually pretty street-level so to grab a
lot of these street-level characters you
know to grab Luke Cage to grab Jessica
Jones to grab Iron Fist you know Carol
Danvers and Ben Grimm being really the
only two major powerhouses here works
not pretty well it really kind of gives
you the idea of the balance of the the
New Avengers landscape itself but from
here this is when we started to get into
Dan Slott kind of thinning the herd in
terms of the roster of the of the
Amazing Spiderman title in the sense
that we basically have Marla Jameson and
we have Aunt May spinning you know kind
of a spa weekend together now for those
of you guys who are reading a clone
conspiracy for Jay jonah Jameson scene
the return of Marla this is the story
where she dies this is a story where she
basically perishes and that's why it was
so huge but I hope that with this this
video you guys are kind of starting to
see how you know all the amazing
spider-man stuff just spin
not a damn slots run there's just one
great big giant cohesive story it's not
like it's a whole bunch of disconnected
one-shots or volumes like it tells one
great big cohesive adventure and that's
why I really love dance lots to run and
be honest like I really enjoy his
spider-man riding especially what's
going on right now but you know with
Alice there's some ice forces you know
breaking into the spa facility we
basically have you know Aunt May and
Marla you know hiding out as best they
can trying to keep from getting caught
up in the conflict and that's really
just the nature of this battle right I
mean I wouldn't say it's a battle that
stretches across the entire city but it
is a battle that is that's stretching
into some some heavily populated areas
now at the same time spider-man also
comes to the realization that the
communications systems between Alastair
Smythe and his forces that they're not
actually beams instead they're basically
cybernetic organisms in a lot of ways
there are characters like you know like
scorpion there are actual people who
have cybernetic modifications given to
them by Alastair smite but for the most
part it's basically a communication
system that has to be taken down and so
what he does is he races back to Horizon
labs for the purpose of constructing a
device the problem with this is that
when he arrives
max Modell is there and Maxwell Adel
says look I want to talk to you about
spider-man
and I want to talk to you about Peter
Parker now the way the Dan Slott does
this is actually kind of cool he sort of
messes with us a little bit in the sense
that it's like Maxwell knows that Peter
Parker spider-man but it's like he
pretends not to know now down slot
doesn't tell us that that's just kind of
how I interpreted this and the reason
why is because max Modell says look you
know I know about you and spider-man and
you know because of the fact that you
disappear every time spider-man shows up
it leads me to only one logical
conclusion that you basically Spy man
hires you to build his weaponry and
gadgets now this seems almost like one
of those things like one of those
situations where somebody is basically
like max Waddell's covering for Peter
Parker he's like hey man like I know
about you and spider-man and Peter
Parker is like what do you mean he's
like well I know as smart as I am
I know that spider-man hires you to do
his weaponry right wink-wink nudge-nudge
that's the conduit that's that's the way
it seems to come across it was like the
official story is that he hires you to
do his weaponry now again whether or not
max Modell actually knows at this point
right now is kind of left ambiguous
instead you know max well now basically
rolls with the punches and says hey look
if what spider-man is looking to do is
to have a device that will disrupt the
communication systems the biomagnetic
communication systems between Alastair
Smythe and his cybernetic creations then
you know I can help you achieve that the
problem with this is that it's literally
going to disrupt the bio electric field
and so what that means is that anybody
caught in the blast if they have any
kind of enhanced abilities you know
anything like that they're gonna lose
those abilities it's basically max
Modell saying if spider-man is caught in
the blast you know you'll lose some of
the spider abilities now how much he'll
lose or whether or not he'll lose
everything is unknown but it will
physically impact him and so because of
that we basically have you know
spider-man returning to the conflict
facing off against you all these
different forces of Alastair Smith sort
of you know leading everybody away and
that's that's that's really the case
it's everybody kind of making a mad dash
trying to get away as best they can you
know you have Robbie Robertson who's
talking with with with Jessica Jones and
Carol Danvers to say look you know these
things are here for me because they're
going after Jay jonah Jameson get me out
of here and everybody else around here
will be safe and of course they whisk
him away at the same time with me with
with Jay jonah Jameson being mayor his
motorcade is getting him out of New York
and getting him to New Jersey but he's
still being followed I so because of
this Peter Parker in his conflict
against the scorpion basically activates
this bioelectric EMP more or less and
when he does it just it seems to
scramble the brain of Peter Parker not
in the sense of like he loses his
memories and everything but in the sense
that it impacts him in some form or
fashion but he doesn't quite know how at
the same time it also impacts an impact
scorpion and the issue is that you know
in the aftermath of all this that really
Peter Parker's forced to kind of faceoff
directly against Alastair Smith as the
Spider Slayer and this is when we learn
on the impact that it has that
spider-man is basically lost his spider
sense he's not alerted to wouldn't win
in it when I thought that's coming now
on the surface it's just kind of like
well he's still you know that's not a
huge deal he's still got super-strength
and he's got super speed and so on and
so forth another spider sense is what
made spider-man unique that's why you
know if you if you look at anybody who
says hey give me like the 10 most
powerful heroes the 10 you know most
capable superheroes in Marvel Comics a
lot of people will always put spider-man
up there and it's not because of the
fact that he has strengths and things
like that I mean even if he wasn't
pulling his punches he's not as strong
as like the Sentry he's under strong is
like Hyperion he's not as fast as either
you know he basically has your
run-of-the-mill superpowers the spider
sense is what made him so capable
because that's what allowed him to dodge
attacks that's what allowed him to you
know have some measure of knowing what
the enemy was gonna do
before they did it it didn't mean he
could read minds but it means he could
react before they even laid a hit in the
first place
it always kept him one step ahead but if
he doesn't have that then he's just like
a guy with super strength and super
speed and he can climb walls and that's
it but the cool thing about this or at
least what seems to happen here anyway
is that in the middle of this fight
Alastair Smith kind of makes this
last-ditch effort to try to take out Jay
jonah Jameson but Marla jumps in the way
now Peter Parker is able to use the
distraction to basically pummel Alastair
Smith well the problem is that with
Marla basically killed Jay jonah jameson
or at least the final words that she
says to him is don't blame other people
you know don't don't spend your life
being any no spend your life being
hateful don't blame spider-man
he'll just blame Alastair Smith he's the
one that did this but in the end Jay
jonah Jameson doesn't do that instead
Judi Jo Jameson says that it's not
spider-man's fault it's not Alastair
Smith's fault or smize fault it is Jay
jonah Jameson's fault it's his own fault
for putting her in harm's way like this
because it's Jay jonah Jameson looking
at his past actions and basically saying
they're all coming back to haunt him all
the tabloids although the articles that
he published in The Daily Bugle all the
things that he said about all these
villains and so on and so forth it was
only a matter of time before they came
back to haunt him and when they did it
was gonna end up taking away something
that he valued a lot and it ultimately
ended up being his wife Marla
alright so picking up with the return of
antivenom or I guess really you know the
amazing spider-man is really what we're
doing again this is all part of Dance
Lots run and this is the cool thing is
because Dan Slott again you know use the
the early aspects of his run to clean
out a lot of the stuff that he didn't
really care for with regards to this
whole committee ran amazing spider-man
series and so because of that you know
the the return of antivenom is designed
to really just deal with Martin Lee now
again we talked you know before about
how Martin Lee was one side at the same
point you had the Martin Lee personality
and you had the mr. negative personality
mr. negative knew about Martin Lee but
Martin Lee didn't know about mr.
negative of course Martin Lee being a
legitimate guy a guy that basically ran
a charity centre but mr. negative was
this you know mr. Hyde persona kind of
thing where he basically used the chair
or said a charity centre as a front for
drug running money laundering all these
criminal schemes that he could basically
run out of New York now this also deals
a lot with anti-venom in the sense that
Eddie Brock is looking to basically
eliminate Martin Lee because you get
sitters Martin Lee to be a cancer on the
society itself
a lot of this really just said or at
least that the lead story initially
picks up is the whole idea that that
antivenom just kind of busts in in the
middle of a of a drug bust or I'm sorry
I have a drug deal by Martin Lee's guys
and starts to take them all out the
problem is that partway through this
we're actually met by the arrival of the
race now this is kind of a weird
situation here because the Wraiths was a
character that predates Dan Slott and
you'll really like one more day predates
that by maybe 20 years or something like
that the rate that you know brian de
wolf originally appeared in like 1985 i
want to say was Peter Parker the
spectacular spider-man or something like
that
he appeared quite some time ago he was a
Sal Buscema
creation and maybe a bill Mantlo
creation but basically he was just kind
of one of these these aspects of
bolstering the spider-man mythos adding
new characters and he was a vigilante
with psionic powers and there's a whole
weird origin story that goes into him
but he was kind of like this on again
off again a lie at the same time the
brian de wolf persona that we knew was
basically killed off in the punisher so
the idea here is what in the heck is
going on who is this version of the
wraith which is kind of crazy now of
course Dan Slott teases us a little bit
when one of the people asked like who
are you know one of these guys asked who
are you what are you doing here and this
person says well I'll reveal my identity
but we never find out what it is instead
we just kind of switch over to to
anti-venom as he takes out the last of
these guys finally tracks downward as
the Wraith is gone only to discover that
this is Jean dewolff now this being Jean
dewolff
should technically be impossible because
Jean dewolff is dead like she was she
was shot of course she was the sister of
Brian de Wolfe the original Wraith she
was a detective that worked alongside
Peter Parker spider-man for quite some
time she was an ally to a lot of the
superhero community she was almost like
this this misty night s character except
where misty night was kind of like an
information broker for you know
street-level heroes and so on and so
forth
a Jean dewolff kind of operated by
passing information from within the
police precinct itself to keep
superheroes on the up-and-up to let them
always know what the police are doing
what they're trying to track down so
that superheroes could go track down
these crimes you know and and deal with
people if they didn't think the police
could pull it off on their own the
problem is that with Jean dewolff being
dead and most everybody knowing that
she's dead the question is who is this
chick who is this girl now from here
again we jump back to to Peter Parker
this is always kind of a cool thing
because again you know Dan Slott tells
us hey look Carly Cooper does not know
that Peter Parker is spider-man she has
no idea about this instead she's just
like yeah a beautiful
like congratulations on your big day now
we don't know what the big day is
something big is apparently happening at
Horizon lives and it's kind of cool
because Dan Slott toys with this Peter
Parker goes to meets with max Modell you
know he shows Maximo Dell an experiment
or I guess an object he's been working
on a helmet that can withstand virtually
any kind of collision without damage to
it um is just like a lot of these things
that are that are sort of going on with
his own individual character but then we
find out that the big day is that Peter
Parker was published an American science
journal and what this does is it gives a
lot of legitimacy to Peter Parker he's
like yeah hit it big time like it's
really funny because it's like Peter
Parker's getting all the things that he
hoped for and instead of just being this
kid who's selling photographs to the
Daily Bugle playing at day by day trying
to be a superhero being broke all the
time trying to balance you know romance
and so on and so forth but he's actually
hitting a big time he's actually
achieving all the goals that he set out
to achieve now the funny thing here too
is that he talks to Aunt May and Aunt
May is like oh you're an American
science journal is like well that's nice
it's like it's like the grandmas
response to being you know to you being
happy about something that they don't
understand but then we find out that she
understands perfectly that she actually
printed off a ton of copies or ordered a
ton of copies and she's been handing it
out to everybody in the feast shelter
she's like yeah like my nephew was an
American science journal like I said
it's so cool and it's so exciting but of
course again because of the fact that
antivenom knows that the whole martin
lee mr- persona is operating out of the
feesh shelter because he's using it as a
way to basically run drugs to engage in
human trafficking different things like
that he's basically operating in this
location albeit in a disguise in order
to figure out what's going on to make a
move here now of course with regards to
Martin Lee being guarded by his inner
demons Martin Lee actually goes to visit
or at least goes out to shake the hand
of on may to thank her for all of her
work but then this is when we get a
really cool situation
somewhere along the line Aunt May had
witnessed Martin Lee killing one of his
henchmen and her reaction was oh my god
I've got to tell somebody about this but
then Martin Lee had basically touched
her and wiped her mind so that she
didn't recall the incident now of course
this causes aunt Mae to pass out and
what this does is this puts a bit of a
panic in the situation right I mean it
puts kind of a kick in the wheel because
now Peter Parker's responding to you
know the whole incident with Aunt May
while at the same time trying to be a
superhero and that's really that's
that's really how things go and when it
comes to the character with every you
know single spider-man story I wouldn't
go as far as to say this like
May's been injured again you know we
gotta you got to get her off to the
hospital and Peter Parker's got to
respond it's not always that situation
but with every spider-man story there's
always a scenario that's injected where
it kind of puts a bit of panic into the
situation like will Peter Parker make it
there in time that's one of the reasons
why a lot of fans still love spider-man
stories so much or at least loved it in
the early days when Dan Slott started
writing it is because it maintained a
lot of the older themes of spider-man
you know from the era when his character
was so popular and remained so popular
because it was this idea that is like
will spider-man get there in time you
know what that's this whole situation
but during this is also Dan Slott
showing us again where Eddie Brock
stands that's the cool thing you know
whether it was Zeb Welles who was
writing you know the whole anti venom
Punisher team-up whether it is dance
when he originally introduced anti-venom
to the spider-man mythos it was Eddie
Brock trying to be a good guy and what
he does is he kind of chastises himself
for not acting sooner he's like I should
have done something sooner I should have
acted sooner otherwise Aunt May would
never have been in danger that's kind of
the kicker here is because with Aunt May
being as old as she is this could result
in her dying like this could this could
result in her death because she's old
she's fragile
you know she's almost done with all her
living as it is something like this
could result in her being killed and so
of course the aunt even who kind of
jumps into the whole situation right you
know and again this is Dan Slott saying
hey guys let's just kind of engineer a
situation where spider-man and
anti-venom fight one another because
again spider-man an anti-venom teaming
up to a degree was only situational in
the sense that it was spider-man not
really knowing what anti-venom was about
just knowing that Eddie Brock was
claiming to try to be a good guy but in
this moment when spider-man arrives on
the scene and anti-venom is tearing over
the roof of a car with Martin Lee inside
spider-man's reaction is Martin he's a
good guy Martin Lee is the the head of
the of the feast shelter that guys on a
criminal that guy's legitimate dude and
so in his mind Eddie Brock's reverted
back to being a criminal again and so of
course this just kind of dissolves down
into a fight between the two and they
just you know they just sort of start
going at it it's actually cool to see
them you know going against one another
because remember with anti-venom
whenever he's in the vicinity of Peter
Parker he sends his power is all into a
caddywhompus and they just kind of start
going crazy and so because of that Peter
starts losing a lot of his abilities
being unable to tap into them being
unable to be as efficient as he normally
is and it's just a way for Dan Slott to
basically introduce anti-venom in in a
fashion that gives them kind of an upper
hand on on Peter Parker and that's why
it's cool is because anti-venom keeps
saying the entire time like I'm trying
to be
good guy I'm trying to be a good guy
just listen stop fighting me and just
listen you know and so finally he gets
the upper hand on Peter Parker right I
mean Martin Lee makes his escape you
know his guys get away finally he gets
his hands on Peter Parker and he
basically takes them captive the problem
is that Eddie Brock takes into what used
to be a meth lab and it's kind of messed
up because Peter Parker's like you did
smells funny in here he's like well the
people that ran this before they were
running a meth lab and I ran them all
out but I'm putting you here now to just
basically keep you out of the way you
know of course again because of the fact
that antivenoms webbing is filled with
the antibodies that his body houses in
order to give his powers by man can't
just break out you know you can't just
escape by normal means so the cool thing
about this is Eddie Brock talks to mrs.
look man Martin Lee is mr- like you know
who mr. negative is you've never been
able to catch him but you know who mr.
negative is he's this warlord of
Chinatown you know this running all
these these drugs and people and and
money laundering and all this kind of
stuff the reason why you've never caught
him is because he's Martin Lee because
whenever you like you've seen him a
million times you just didn't know it
was him now of course Peter Parker's
response is well this is ridiculous
there's no way that that's the case but
the other thing to remember here is that
Peter Parker doesn't have a spider sense
remember he lost that and so it wasn't
like he you know came across mr. Lee and
his spider sense activated he didn't
have any way to know he just kind of has
to take Eddie Brock at his word and
that's why Peter losing his spider sense
it's kind of cool here you know because
if it turned out that he did have a
spider since any came across Martin Lee
it would almost immediately kicked off
because remember Martin Lee in this part
of the story is mr. negative just posing
as Martin Lee and so he's still a bad
guy then Peter Parker spider says would
have immediately tipped him off to that
and been like well mr. negatives here
you know and so it really creates a
school situation where spider-man just
kind of has to trust Eddie Brock now of
course Eddie Brock doesn't do anything
to benefit him thought himself in this
situation he leaves Peter Parker tied up
to a pole and what used to be a meth lab
and then races off to try to find Martin
Lee before anything and this is why this
is why I love the spider-man comics so
much the way Dan Slott wrote him the
funny thing about this is that Peter
Parker's trying to make his escape right
like he has to grab acetone and he
basically just kind of asked to burn
himself you know as he's trying to get
himself out of this spider suit the
problem is that by the time he does
about this Hani burns himself and gets
himself out of the suit eighty venom
shows up and puts puts the you know
starts covering him in webbing again
it's like really like I just went
through
all this only to turn around and be
covered in this goo yet again it's just
kind of it's that parker luck it's just
one of those inconvenient moments I
guess but from a year we pick up with
with with Carly Cooper because again you
know Carly Cooper is just kind of
watching all these events unfold she's
kind of you know trying to figure out
what's going on with regards to all
these sightings of the way these rumors
that Jean dewolff is alive again this is
cool because it gives us this other part
of this story that we wouldn't normally
see but what happens it's Carly Cooper
you know being as smart as she is says
look ghosts don't have body heat they
just don't have body that's not the way
it works and so when she's Auto she's
witnessing the wraith who's basically
you know kind of tormenting a guy for
the purpose of trying to trying to gain
information on what it is that mr.
negative is doing next
Carly Cooper is watching all the events
unfold and she says that's an actual
person that's not there's no way that's
Jean dewolff
and if it is then how did she come back
from the dead and so it's just like
that's got to be somebody posing as Jean
dewolff I don't want to know who that
person is now following this whole trail
of what's going on with regards to the
right we kind of follow Carly Cooper as
she goes through this whole you know
process of trying to figure out what's
going on with Gina wolf and that's one
of the reasons why this is kind of cool
is because it's like this little
intricate gooding of a side story and
with regards to this whole lot this
whole telling and what we find out is
carly cooper goes to a place called the
special crimes evidence storage and what
this is is basically a location where
they store things you know like the
glider of green goblin bombs and you
know Mysterio's tech and so on and so
forth just super villains whose gears
and gadgets have been confiscated by the
police after their arrest the problem
with this is that Carly Cooper is
basically told by the officer on the
scene that evidence from that place
doesn't go missing instead that it was
destroyed that there was a pumpkin bomb
that had went off and all the evidence
was completely obliterated but as Carly
Cooper's going through and looking at
all this she comes to the realization
that there was only one person who was
around that evidence room at the time of
the accident
and that was captain yuri Watanabe and
so the idea here is that a member of the
police force in New York is masquerading
as the Wraith which is actually kind of
cool is that you kind of an interesting
concept here so wildly important it's
not the most important thing by any
stretch of the imagination it's just
kind of interesting but from here we
switch back to the Metropolitan Museum
of Art with Peter Parker and anti-venom
of course anti-venom says hey look this
is where
homey this is where they're doing their
next drug meeting you know I'm putting
you here out of sight because I want you
to see this I want you to see that
Martin Lee is mr. negative now the funny
thing about this is that mr. negative
has a Muramasa blade which is designed
for the purpose of disrupting people's
healing factors healing abilities and it
disrupts healing abilities regardless of
where those abilities come from because
remember when it comes to healing
factors in Marvel Comics whether it's
Wolverine Deadpool Dakin x-23 the
symbionts it doesn't matter all the
healing happens on a cellular level and
so what the Muramasa blade us is it
basically just blocks people neo blocks
their cells from being able to
regenerate and so because of this you
know with Martin Lee showing up here you
know with a mystic blade attacking
anti-venom as long as the blades in his
body he's not gonna be able to heal from
his attacks the kicker to all this is
that while Peter Parker's being held
here by anti-venom well then suddenly we
have Reis showing up and that's kind of
the funny thing is Peter Parker you know
spider-man hadn't really been
investigating the whole Ray thing didn't
really even know it was going on instead
rathe is just here and the whole idea is
that he basically says look lady like
you're telling me you're a ghost you
know that's fine I've met spirits of
vengeance alright I'd met ghostwriter
I've seen people come back from the dead
I know what ghosts are I know the
difference you're not a ghost you're
using technology from Mysterio is what
you're doing and that's a funny thing
because the Wraith is like a thumbs
you know she's being all like mysterious
cloak-and-dagger he's like yeah who use
a mysterious tech right and like a
couple other gadgets so stuff like that
and their way this is kind of like yeah
it's just a funny situation because it's
like the wraith is using all the
technology but peter parker seen before
when he's far as various villains so
it's nothing new to him you know it's
just kind of like that's you just use
the stuff that I've seen before just
somebody else doing it now of course the
allegiance the Alliance's is short-lived
I mean only insofar that it lasts long
enough for Peter Parker and Rayce to
join forces with anti-venom and take out
you know mr. negative skies which they
you know for the most part succeed in
doing you know taking him out pretty
easily the issue with this is that of
course you know he ends up throwing his
death yes you know a poison gas that
will basically take most people out but
in response to this of course you have
your Parker who basically gets the upper
hand in this major conflict and where
mr. negative seems to make his escape
and he seems to get away a wraith ends
up using the technology in her suit to
basically analyze the face of mr.
negative do a side-by-side comparison
with a 97% accuracy match to verify that
venom was telling the truth that mr.
negative is Martin Lee and so because of
that smart emancipation he was kind of
forced to trust an Tibet I'm like well I
guess he was right yeah I guess he was
right when he said that like mr.
negative was Martin Lee and the result
is that he ends up going forward having
to do not really trust Eddie Brock so to
speak but give him a little more
credence that he originally gave him in
addition to this the face of Martin Lee
and mr. Negi was just gonna plastered
all over the place I mean it's an
attitude frontline has sent out to the
Daily Bugle it's put on the national
news the whole nine yards and so
everybody knows that Martin Lee and mr.
negative in the same person that they're
basically criminals and so because of
that it's more or less everything that
mr. negative has worked for has
essentially just come crashing down
around him and so because of that you
know where mr. negative makes his escape
you know where he's able to get away
this results in again this kind of mini
alliance so to speak but it's also carly
cooper tracking down yuri Watanabe and
saying why did you decide to Don the
mask of Wraith why did you decide to go
on and be this you know vigilante
character well of course Watanabe says
we were both friends of Jean dewolff we
both know who she was
we were both friends of hers she was
shot in cold blood it was a senseless
murder
I wanted to basically carry on the
mantle of the Wraith I wanted people to
believe that she was back I wanted to
inspire fear in the hearts and minds of
individuals which is actually kind of a
cool concept but in the end it doesn't
really matter I mean it's kind of a cool
situation to see the way through turn to
a degree but it doesn't have like any
major bearing on events that go on it's
really just kind of part of this mini
story in the background in order to kind
of beef things up a bit you know in
order to give it a little bit more than
just hey Peter Parker doesn't know if he
can trust anti-venom and now antivenoms
gonna prove him wrong you know it's just
kind of adding a little bit of
information but at the end of the day
things just kind of wind down with Peter
Parker talking to Carly Cooper and this
idea that he may reveal his identity to
her but instead he doesn't you know
where she keeps asking questions where
she keeps you know kind of poking and
prodding about his relationship with
spider-man he basically offers the exact
same explanation that he gave max Modell
when he's like well I'm not spider-man
maybe he says I basically just build
spider-man's gadgets for him and Carly
Cooper takes it as gospel truth she's
like I knew it I knew that you were
somehow involved with spider-man this is
kind of damn tslot teasing that things
may end up becoming a little more
interesting with regards to the
relationship between the two but again
at this point we don't really know how
that's going to flesh out
okay so spider versus I'm not
spider-verse spider versus later
Spider Island is right around the corner
and in truth the Spider Island actually
has a couple of like pre luge those you
guys who don't know whenever it comes to
crossover events whether it's lined wide
which means it's like everybody it goes
through Avengers x-men Inhumans the
whole nine yards or if it's just like a
standalone story that pertains to a
character or a group of people there's
usually always like a lead-in for
example with civil war two there was the
road to Civil War two but civil war one
there was the road to Civil War one they
usually always have those the road to
secret invasion
there's always pre ludes that lady and
lead into it sometimes it's just like a
whole bunch of stories for example the
lead into Dark Reign was house of M
Avengers disassembled Civil War Secret
Invasion I mean it was everything
leading up to Dark Reign there are a lot
of things going on um siege was a really
good story that tied into Dark Reign but
with regards to to Spider Island the
best prelude I think that's offered is a
story called infested and the reason why
is because what this does is it tells us
how it all starts the prologue so to
speak that is to say like amazing
spider-man number 665 I think it is it
kind of goes into it but it's not nearly
as important I don't think as the
infested story so what this does is this
picks up with Miles Warren and the
reason why is because it's the most
logical person to choose when it comes
to the history of Marvel Comics and
really in the spider-man mythos miles
war and really his most significant role
prior to this was Clone Saga despite the
fact that that story was heated I mean
it was panned people hated that story
because it was basically Marvel
introducing the notion of replacing
Peter Parker with a clone Ben Reilly
what was supposed to be a story that
would basically simplify the spider-man
mythos turned out to be anything but you
go read any interview from anybody who
is part of that project and they were
like the story was supposed to be short
and before we knew it the whole damn
thing just spiraled out of control to
the point then it was basically insane
and people hated it but miles Warren was
the guy who was behind the cloning of
Peter Parker he knew Peter Parker's
identity he basically created a Caine he
eventually created Ben Reilly and so the
idea was that if Dan Slott is going to
come back and he's going to have someone
give everybody in Manhattan
spider-powers
miles Warren is the most logical person
to choose now what miles Warren does is
he basically goes through and begins
adding or begins modifying the
DNA of bedbugs with spider DNA are
basically giving people the ability to
have spider powers by way of being
bitten by these bedbugs and again that
makes sense because bedbugs are small
they're not something that you normally
look for at least if you if you
basically engage in any measure of
cleanliness you don't expect to look for
a bedbugs and so because of this ebay
basically does kind of pour into the
city of Manhattan now what this does is
it gives us like a series of these
little two or three issues stories and
we'll cover them all here but it gives
us an injuries of these little two or
three issues stories that follow each
individual person when they're granted
these spider powers and how they respond
and it's actually really really cool one
of the first people that we pick up with
is a guy by the name of Richard Davies
now it's kind of ironic here because
Richard Davies is for all intents and
purposes Flash Thompson I mean the way
that his character is portrayed here he
is basically the the jock or something
like that he's picking on the guy who's
basically the nerd it created an
interesting situation here and the
reason why Dan Slott did this is because
when it comes to the Spider Man mythos
it's timeless right I mean Spider Man is
timeless a kid who basically was bitten
by a radioactive spider you know he
learned that with great power comes
great responsibility
that lesson was learned at the expense
of his uncle's life you know it's it's a
beautifully crafted crafted story and
it's the most recognizable thank god
they're not going over that origin story
again and spider-man home company I was
like everybody's biggest fear they were
gonna go over it again but it's a
timeless story and so to kind of see it
rehash a little bit it's interesting
even then Dan Slott says if you ever
want to see real life if you want to see
what people are really like go to the
schoolyard now this is kind of an
archaic stance that dance let's take you
about it's an older ideology and this
was the 1980s you know maybe even the
early 1990s I'd say Dan Slott you're
probably right this is the 2000s this is
the late 2000s so if you're talking
about people in their most basic form if
you're talking about people in in their
most fundamental form that's the
Internet when there's anonymity people
don't have to be don't have to worry
about being held accountable for the
things they say and do and so it's
people in their most basic forms but the
idea here is that this kid there's a
particular person that's being picked on
Richard Davies basically you know games
these spider powers by way of a bite
from one of these bedbugs and then his
spider sense goes off when he realizes
that the guy he's picking on has a gun
and he intends to shoot Richard Davies
now of course what you're Davies is able
to counter he uses a super-strength and
he attacks this guy and kills him in the
process and this is really really cool
because what this is is Dan Slott
drawing on the lessons learned from
ultimate spider-man remember
and the first our twitch comic story is
coming right now you know one in the
very beginning of ultimate spider-man
one of the first lessons Peter Parker
had to learn was that there that he
basically has to pull his punches that
if he didn't pull his punches he would
kill people and so because of that he
basically had to come to this
realization that he can't just go full
in when it comes to fighting various
supervillains that he has to fight
supervillains with with you know being
cogman a cognizant of what he's capable
of Richard Davies wasn't raised with
that lesson he wasn't taught how to use
his powers it's just suddenly he has the
spider sense he just kind of snaps into
action he reflexes and he kills this kid
in the process and the responses that
Richard Davies is basically on the run
he's a fugitive Heidi from the police
and he's wanted for murder now at this
point we switch over to another guy and
the person that we join is Walter
Coleman now watch up Walter Coleman is
kind of like this predecessor to renew
your vows and that was really
interesting thing years because remember
in the world of comics everything has
happened before and it'll all happen
again it's basically the same thing
stories just get recycled every story
that can be told has been told there's a
reason why we're seeing Superman with a
son for the first time now because in a
70 some-odd you're history we've never
seen that before it's new it's fresh but
after a while that story will have been
told where do you go from there so what
we do here is with Walter Coleman he
takes us kind of renew your vows Stan's
the reason why I say that is because
during the events of secret Wars Marvel
released the story you know spider-man
renew your vows and what it was was kind
of like this this throwback to fans who
really wanted to see Peter Parker and
Mary Jane Watson get back together and
they wanted to see how that life would
function with renew your vows it was
basically Peter Parker walking away from
being a superhero a new villain named
the region had shown up on the scene he
was basically kidnapping superheroes he
was using them keeping them prisoner in
the process and the result was that
during this massive battle between what
was left of the Avengers and in Regent
himself Peter Parker had to choose
between Mary Jane and his and his you
know his family or fighting alongside
the Avengers
he chose Mary Jane he left the Avengers
behind and he basically had to hide he
had to basically pretend that he wasn't
a superhero his family had to follow the
exact same pattern this very much takes
the same approach and we get these
really cool juxtapositions between
characters between super I'm sorry
between us spider-man and between Walter
Coleman where spider-man is basically
saving people from burning buildings so
on and so forth Walter Coleman is
basically had to watch his neighbors
burn to death and the reason why is
because he said look I got these powers
I have these abilities
yes I could have saved their lives
but I'm a family man I've got a family
to protect you know I'm sorry about
their luck that's their problem you know
I take care of my family first and that
makes sense you know I mean if you're a
person and your family struggling
financially you know and your kids are
hungry you don't fix a sandwich for the
family across the street you fix a
sandwich for your kids you keep your
house in order
you take care of your house and then you
worry about those guys across the street
and if they don't make it that's their
problem not yours and so the whole idea
here is that it gives us this really
really cool situation it was this very
real-world how people should normally
function type of situation and it comes
out kind of cool but in the end it's
just another instance where a person
just uses their powers it really doesn't
use their powers and takes it in a
completely different direction but at
this point we switch over to a guy named
Mattie Oh cauldron I think is how you
pronounce his last name but again this
is a guy who basically is just you know
supplying drugs he's basically a drug
dealer that's really it you know just a
drug runner here and he's fighting a
fighting cloak-and-dagger there's no
real huge story here it's basically just
like cloak-and-dagger are beginning to
realize that people are popping up on
the scene that have the powers of
spider-man and it creates a really
interesting situation because for them
they don't quite know how to handle this
remember when it comes to Peter Parker
facing off against him is a very
dangerous situation because right now he
doesn't have a spider sense of course we
saw that with spider-man big-time he
lost his spider sense but for those
individuals that do have it the spider
sense is what you spider-man on top if
you take spider-man's spider-sense away
well then he's just got the same power
that everybody else has he's got
super-strength SuperSpeed durability and
he can crawl on walls which is kind of
cool he can shoot webbing but that's it
I mean you know without a spider since
he can't be alerted to danger
so all it would take is the Punisher
sitting on top of a roof a hundred yards
away and Peter Parker's not with us
anymore that's all it really takes I
mean we saw that during original sin
right you know during the whole original
sin story when Nick Fury was established
as being the man on the wall where he
was basically taking care of threats
within the earth and beyond the earth
when Peter Parker first popped up Nick
Fury was gonna kill him in that time
period between when Peter Parker first
became spider-man before his fighters
since fully developed and he began to
understand how it works Nick Fury came
across him was sitting on a rooftop took
aim and plan to kill him but the Nick
Fury said well no I think this is a good
guy and Peter Parker live it was one of
those really cool retcons where it was
like you know Peter Parker was a bullet
well I'm sorry was was a trigger pull
away from being killed and so it was a
really cool situation but again from
here we switch over to
Schanke there we go and she's basically
like Bruce
in the Marvel Universe I mean I have a
hard time finding anybody who would
refute that claim that's basically what
he is it's cool
I love shang-chi he's a really cool
character but he's basically Bruce Lee
in the end the Marvel Universe but the
issue here is remember because Peter
Parker doesn't have his spider sense he
has to essentially rely on other means
to begin getting around his guys the way
he normally would because it with with
Peter Parker
I wouldn't say his spider sense was a
crutch so much as I would say his spider
sense was an intrinsic part of who he
was you know it was an arm it was a leg
it was a it was a foot you know it was
it was a fist it was very much an
intrinsic part of what his character was
he relied on his spider since as much as
he relied on his agility his webbing all
that kind of good stuff to have it taken
away means that now he has to be able to
compensate and this is cool because what
he does is he develops his own martial
arts style called the way of the spider
the sad thing is that he uses it twice
in Spider Island and I don't think we
ever see it again that's the saddest
thing about this because he basically
gets his spider sense back he's like
well I don't really need that anymore
you know and that's it it kind of sucks
you know but the cool thing is that you
know with regards to this whole training
sequence he's really learning from one
of the greatest martial artists in the
entirety of the of the Marvel Universe
but what we do is we pick up you know
again this is really really fast we pick
up with a few days after this training
session I guess over the course these
training sessions with spider-man
leaving and we find out that all of this
is being washed by the new Madame web
Julia carpenter now the concept of
Madame web is interesting in the realm
of spider-man remember when Dan Slott
took over the title you know everything
really I guess the the role of Spider
Island was kind of grabbing all these
different stories that were leading up
to it grabbing all these things in the
spider-man mythos and saying here's what
I want to keep here's what I don't want
to keep and Spider Island serve the
purpose of just getting rid of
everything that Dan Slott didn't want to
keep you know getting rid of all that
said well we'll cross that bridge when
we get to Spider Island but madam web
was kind of like this holdover from an
earlier time and in spider-man comics
but madam web is tied intrinsically into
the web of life and destiny or destiny
in life whatever you call it and that's
where people seem to get confused in in
Marvel Comics in the spider-man mythos
that was a huge point in spider-verse a
lot of people were thrown off by the web
of destiny in life so let's let's talk
about this for a second because this is
more important than Madame web the
Madame web is just like an Oracle all
right you can just see the future that's
all she can do it's cool whatever she's
a plot device in Spider Island so um the
web of life and destiny is this really
cool thing because in marvel
every group every subgroup of
superheroes has its own kind of access
to the multiverse and it's not like
Marvel engineered it to be that way it's
not like in 1962 with Fantastic Four
whatever it was tomorrow you know that
the Stan Lee and Jack Kirby sat down and
said okay guys over the course of the
next 50 years we're going to lay out
multiversal access for these different
individual teams it just kind of
progressed that way it just kind of
turned out to be that way it's cool but
it turned out to be that way for example
the British superhero team Excalibur has
what's called the lighthouse and the
lighthouse is basically a portal more or
less I mean you know you go into it you
can access the Captain Britain Corps
that's what you know Brian Braddock does
he goes into the lighthouse he accesses
the omniversal omniversal Development
Court I think is what it's called
and I the Captain Britain Corps this
multiversal group of Captain Britain's
from across the multiverse in the mutant
landscape you have what's called the
m'kraan crystal if you imagine the
multiverse to be a hallway of doors each
door going to a different universe the
m'kraan crystal is that door each
universe has its own m'kraan crystal
that's why if you were to destroy the
m'kraan crystal in any given universe it
would be tantamount to blowing the door
off the hinge in which case all the
energies of the multiverse would just
come pouring in and it would lead to the
destruction of that of that universe
itself and then eventually the
multiverse would just condense in on
itself and the multiverse would be
destroyed so it creates kind of a weird
situation and in the realm of
traditional superheroes the Fantastic
Four the Avengers so on and so forth we
have the negative zone you know in in
all the multiverse there's only one
negative zone in any universe can access
it the Ultimate Universe can access it
the main Marvel Universe can access it
they all have access to the negative
zone the web of a web of life and
destiny is the exact same way the
difference here is that individuals who
can tap into the web of life and destiny
wherever you want to call it can see the
future and that's the huge difference
when it comes to all the other aspects
of multiverse all access the lighthouse
the negative zone the m'kraan crystal
those individuals cannot see the future
the only exception that I think is maybe
the white phoenix of the crown jean grey
but even then I'm not gonna swear to
that people who can who can basically
access that can can end up seeing in the
future so a crease god of a really cool
really cool situation with regards to
the spider-man mythos but yeah I mean
the whole intensive thing is really just
designed to serve the purpose of saying
hey guys here are the events that are
leading up to it you know Madame web is
basically looking into the future and
saying the spiders are coming you know
there's going to be this great big huge
conflict that's massive you know
calamity really you know of
Javad proportions in New York which we
know is going to be Spider Island okay
so getting into Spider Island what I
wanted to do was just go ahead and and
throw this this prologue and here anyway
in this video the reason why is just
because of the fact that there are a few
things here in this prologue that will
be important with regards to the story
not insane not anything that we could
let go without talking about I mean we
could just cover in the rest of the
video but I wanted to go ahead and just
throw it in here anyway because it can't
hurt it beats up the video and it's
never a bad thing but the cool thing is
that for the most part when it comes to
spider-man in this prologue it's really
just kind of like his goings on it's
cool just like here's what spider-man
does when he does things but it's also
kind of Dan Slott saying hey guys there
are some things going on in the
background that at first don't seem
relevant but become relevant later on
specifically some guys who have
committed some robberies now the reason
these guys committing these robberies is
because they've become more brazen with
these spider-man powers while they don't
necessarily manifest right off the bat
they are becoming a little more
adventurous they are becoming a little
more dangerous than normally would be
because for them they kind of feel like
they're they're indestructible you know
just because of the fact that they
basically have the same ability as a
spider-man now these criminals are
wrapped up by Peter Parker pretty fast
and of course you just kind of races off
just because of the Miss New York
there's always a crime going on
somewhere so for Peter Parker you can't
just linger around just kind of like
okay these guys are wrapped up you know
the cops are here we'll call it a day I
got a bail out now the cool thing about
this is we also pick up with Jay jonah
Jameson I'll keep in mind Jameson's
currently mayor of New York the issue
with this is that his approval ratings
are at an all-time low
and the reason why is because he hates
spider-man and he makes no bones about
the fact that he hates spider-man now
under normal circumstances this wouldn't
be a problem but everybody in the city
loves spider-man and so they hate the
mayor because he hates spider-man it's
just one of these funny eight one of
these funny little situations but it's
also a J John Jameson on the other side
of the coin on the other side of the
line and since that when he was running
the Daily Bugle he was going through and
just lambasted spider-man all the time
you know spider-man sucks spider-man's a
minute so uncivil it's one of the things
that we loved about its character well
now the Daily Bugle is running these
these campaigns against Jay jonah
Jameson so now he's like well I don't
like being on the other side it's not
fair you know the Daily Bugle is wrong
it's just one of these things were it's
like be damned with the facts my
opinions right but again you know a lot
of this is just kind of Peter doing his
own thing it's him just kind of you know
being a hero and doing whatever he does
in his
normal time but one of these funny
little moments that we get is in in
horizon labs and that's why I really
like dance lots riding because it's just
the funny little moments that make the
story so interesting with an experiment
that he's basically you know showing to
max Modell and the rest of the guys at
horizon labs max Bodell makes the
comment that you can't tack the number
2000 to the end of something and it
becomes crueler which I beg to differ
like imagine comics explain mm like
explaining comics to you and the voice
of Morgan Freeman like it'd be pretty
funny it'd be kind of cool but it's just
one of those funny little moments me
nothing too major but with regards to
the whole leader with regard as being
like a tried and true prologue to the
whole element of Spider Island this is
when we start to see people manifesting
abilities this comes in a couple
different forms the first is through
carly cooper the whole idea with Carly
is that while she's currently on the
scene of this crime remember she's a
forensic scientist she watches a couple
of these criminals break free of their
wedding this is something that should
normally never be allowed to happen the
webbing is designed to easily you know
keep a normal human being contained the
only individuals that can break out of
Peter Parker's webbing are people with
super strength so this is Dan Slott
saying their spider powers are starting
to emerge they're basically gaining the
abilities of spider-man now in response
to this Carly Cooper immediately takes
out one of these guys and this is Dan
Slott telling us Carly Cooper now has
super strength and that's the way this
really begins to unfold is that these
small little glimpses these small little
drops in there of people gaining all
these different abilities now from here
we pick up with the jackal and we pick
up with the Jackals henchmen now again
at this point we don't really know who
this henchman is all we know is that
he's just a guy that's there with the
jackal and what jackal does as he
presents a card to one of these people
one of these individuals who've
developed spider powers and says be at
this location tomorrow and so the idea
is that there's a kind of gathering of
sorts where the jackal will do with that
we don't quite know yet but again
switching over to the Future Foundation
keep in mind all of this comes after
Hickman's Fantastic Four so because of
that Peter Parker is still part of the
Future Foundation that's still very much
a world that he plays you know this kind
of scientific community and it works out
for his character because the Peter
Parker is part of Future Foundation and
as part of horizon labs it means he has
access to all the science concepts that
the Future Foundation is coming up with
under Reed Richards the smartest man of
the Marvel Universe and he can extend
those to Horizon labs so while I
wouldn't say that he's a double agent it
don't allow him to cheat a little bit it
doesn't allow him to basically grab
ideas that may not necessarily be his
own that he's helped to contribute to
you and then roll them
over into horizon labs but the issue
with this is that while all this is
happening individuals from around New
York are manifesting spider-powers
they're manifesting spider abilities now
the effects of this are wide and ranging
I mean you know some people are only
developing a spider sense and the powers
count you know the strength and speed
come later
some people are developing strength and
speed and the spider sense comes later
but they're all having these kind of
physical reactions so to the doctors of
New York there's some kind of virus
that's going around that's infecting the
city on a massive scale and no one quite
knows how to handle it now at this point
we pick up with the jackal again and we
have him back in his laboratory of
course you know where he's continuing to
experiment and we basically have this
woman who's in shadow now we'll find out
who she is and it's actually gonna be
dance lot returning and then killing off
a little character from from from
spider-man's I really like the holdover
of old spider-man stories but what we
find out is that someone's basically
been kidnapped by the jackal and this
person is being experimented on for the
purpose of serving you know some kind of
role some kind of uh you know I guess
maybe being a Power House member of
jackals group but we also find out this
unknown henchman of jackal is king now
this is really really interesting
because when it came to the character of
Kane in Marvel Comics Kane Parker he
made his debut and web of spider-man
number 119 I think and he was basically
part of Clone Saga this story everybody
hates but the idea is that Kane was kind
of like this holdover from Clone Saga
that Marvel just never really knew how
to get rid of it was like Marvel's dirty
little secret like what do you do with a
character like Kane I mean after Clone
Saga I like there was nothing for him he
was just kind of tumbling down the
rabbit hole of stories and popping up
every once in a while and just becoming
increasingly irrelevant as time went on
and so far the time I got around a
spider island this is probably the most
significant world that he plays leading
into him becoming the second Scarlet
Spider with skull of spider vol 2 that
story is amazing by the way I love
Scarlet Spider with Kane Parker and I
don't know how other people feel about
it but I always thought it was really
really enjoyable but we basically have
this giant spider guy kind of
manifesting but we also find out that
this unknown woman is able to basically
seize control of this spider guy you
know there whoever this giant you know
monster is she's able to seize control
of it and bend it to her will and so
from here we basically pick up with this
revelation that everybody in New York is
developing spider powers they're able to
shoot webbing they have super-strength
they have super speed that can crawl on
walls they basically have all the
abilities of spider-man but for the life
of Peter Parker for his own individual
goings-on Carly Cooper reveals the fact
that she has spider-man's powers now
this is crazy this is this is really
really interesting because what she does
is she kind of tries to corner him a
little bit right and say hey look like
you're friends with spider-man like you
make all this gear because remember
that's kind of been the ongoing lie that
Peter Parker has been telling everybody
that begins to get close to the idea
that he's pure para that he's spider-man
he basically says well no no I'm not
spider-man it's just I helped to develop
spider-man's gear you know all those
different gadgets and all I kind of get
stuff I help him build that and so
that's the lie that Carly Cooper has
been told and it's the lie that she
believes and so in response her idea is
hey look like help me out like have me
you know let me meet with spider-man so
that we could start working together and
he can teach me how to be a superhero
and that seems to be a lot of people's
response to this a lot of people seem to
have this idea that they all want to be
superheroes not only that we end up
meeting up with Miles Warren when
they're not meeting up with a jackal
where he basically passed this note on
to this guy as well as a multitude of
other people show up at this location at
a certain time and the idea of miles
Warren is to cause absolute chaos cause
absolute pandemonium in Bryant Park in
New York by giving everyone who's there
some variation of the spider-man costume
and all these costumes range from the
earliest costumes that Peter Parker wore
when he was spider-man to just you know
costumes you can buy off the shelves all
the way up to his future foundation
costume and so it's it's again no one
really knows who's spider-man is which
spider-man is the right spider-man now
of course we have
remember you have Aunt May you have Jay
jonah Jameson senior they're heading out
to Boston at least you're sitting in an
airport they're not in New York right
now remember we had talked about that
that with regards to the whole Kree
little thing was the idea of basically
assuring them out removing them from the
landscape and sort of shifting them away
that was the whole basis behind this and
so because of that with all these
different folks unfolding all these
different folks popping up with these
you know spider-man powers to the
Avengers the New Avengers the Mighty
Avengers everybody in New York begins to
respond now of course this begs the
question where's like Excalibur at from
Britain I guess we're just kinda like
well that's been a no problem that's New
York we don't care I have no idea but
the cool thing is that when Peter Parker
gets here it's exactly what we would
expect I mean you've got guys who are
wearing the iron spider armor from Civil
War people who are wearing like the
spider-man back in black suit you know
you have people who were wearing the
spider-man suit with the wings you know
people who are wearing those again the
earliest versions every single costume
the spider-man's ever worn exist in some
form or fashion in all these people who
have his outfit so that when the real
Peter Parker shows up no
knows it's him no one believes is him
and that's kind of the crazy thing here
that's what made Spider Island so
interesting in the beginning was because
Peter Parker's blessing turned out to be
a scourge remember an amazing spider-man
number 641 following the events of civil
war that dr. strange or at least had
been revealed that dr. strange cast a
spell at the request of Peter Parker
that removed knowledge of his identity
from the world when he unmasked himself
during civil war in order to lien lend
credence to Tony Stark's claim that if
superheroes came forward they registered
that their secret identities would be
safe that their families would be safe
that following the Civil War event
Marvel had to find some way to put the
genie back in the bottle again and so
that's exactly what happened dr. strange
said okay everybody no one knows the
identity of Peter Parker the only way
they can find out is if Peter Parker
basically reveals it to them directly
that's the only way we're faders happen
to see him without his mask or something
along those lines but the issue is that
when he shows up the Avengers the Mighty
Avengers the whole nine yards they all
start attacking him because in their
mind this isn't Peter Parker this is
just somebody with the powers of
spider-man masquerading as spider-man so
if the fight goes exactly as we would
expect it to in this sense of the The
Avengers and everybody is like hey man
you gotta go you gotta get out of here
if you really are spider-man you need to
leave because all you're doing right now
is you're getting in the way
now what also ends up happening here is
that with Carly Cooper fighting on the
front lines and going against you know
some of these some of these criminals
fighting the small-time guy is not
really facing off against villains Peter
Parker ends up running into Mary Jane
Watson now the cool thing about this is
remember Mary Jane Watson knows that
he's he's spider-man she's one of the
few people that know his identity and
her response is you have to get out
there and you have to do something on
the mind of Peter Parker he's like well
all the superheroes don't know that I'm
spider-man I can't just walk out and
unmask myself but he says what I can do
is I can rally the citizens of New York
now this is extremely important and the
reason why is because Peter Parker goes
on camera broadcasts to the Internet and
says hey if you guys are watching this I
have spider powers I have a spider sense
I have all these different things the
New York that people believe they know
is not the New York that it actually is
people think that everybody in New York
are dicks
that's not true you know there are
people in New York who are hard workers
who believe in truth and fairness and
justice in the American Way if you're
one of those people fight alongside me
be a superhero and he basically rallies
a whole ton of New Yorkers to his side
now
this is actually kind of a cool
revelation because this will be
extremely important once we get back to
the end of this video but following this
you know where Peter Park
these guys to his cause the next step is
okay how do we cure this virus how do we
basically eliminate this entire you know
this this pathogen that's giving
everybody superpowers now the cool thing
is that there are three individuals who
are working diligently on this max
Modell the head of horizon labs Reed
Richards and some unknown guy in cell
number six we don't know who that person
is but the cool idea is that with Reed
Richards and max Modell here if anybody
can find a solution they can that's kind
of the ironic thing about this is
because what Dan Slott does and he says
hey look you've got two of the smartest
men in the world like max Modell Reed
Richards working on a solution surely
they're gonna find a way to cure this
right and it's like well yeah I mean I
assume they are you know that's that's
something that would make sense well
then we shift over to anti-venom
anti-venom is already made cured
remember anti-venom is basically a venom
symbian with antibodies he can cure
anyone of anything and so he begins
going through and basically chasing down
all these individuals who have spider
powers whether they're villains are
whether they're good guys and starts
stripping their abilities away from them
starts taking their abilities away from
each and every one of these guys and it
creates kind of a funny situation
because of our mind it would be like
well I mean why don't they just go to
ant even if he's the Cure why don't they
just go to anti-venom and so at this
point we end up joining a Peter Parker
when he and Carly Cooper end up
travelling again to to the police
precinct because remember that's one of
the one of the reasons why we covered a
lot of these stories with amazing
spider-man a lot of them seemed almost
totally irrelevant and most of them were
but there were little moments here and
there that would make sense when we
talked about the return of wraiths we
had talked about how you know this this
one particular police officer was
basically breaking into the evidence
room and stealing gadgets and equipment
that belonged to villains well that's
the same room that carly cooper and
peter parker go to and what peter parker
does is he says hey look here are a lot
of the things that you can use because
remember the webbing that Carly Cooper
is using is organic webbing but what she
needs is she needs fluids and she needs
starchier foods but she doesn't know
this Peter Parker's just like hey here's
everything you need in order to get your
running back but until that webbing
begins to get back to its full supply
here's some artificial you know web
shooters that will serve the purpose not
only that we ended up picking up with
project rebirth in the Catskill
Mountains now for those of you guys who
are following comics torian's channel
this is the hole agent venom aspect of
Spider Island I imagine he probably
covered that in its videos I'm not sure
I haven't had a chance to watch him yet
I never watch comic story news videos
but when it creates kind of a funny
funny thing because again this shows how
large everything goes in the sense that
spider came you know this giant spider
monster that had popped up earlier in
the story was basically sent on a
mission to to project rebirth now of
course running into agent venom what it
does is it bolsters things out a little
bit it basically increases this entire
landscape because this adds to them to
the possibility of this infection
spreading beyond the borders of New York
and so that's what happens Mayor Jay
jonah jameson begins to realize that
things are becoming more dangerous that
if this infection escapes the island
that these millions of people in
manhattan who all have spider powers
will turn into hundreds of millions of
people across the united states and
eventually billions across the globe if
they do not keep it contained and so in
conjunction you know with these mandroid
suits basically these these next suits
that are used by the NYPD along with a
handful of the Avengers Luke Cage and so
on
they basically begin the process of
blocking off access to New York they
literally start shutting it all down
they start shutting down bridges
shutting down tunnels the whole nine
yards they quite literally quarantine
the entirety of New York hence the
reason why it's called Spider Island
because everybody on the island of
Manhattan has spider powers and so at
this point is the question of how do
they bring this down how do they bring
this to an end well of course the first
step is to basically synthesize a cure
which of course Reed Richards and
Maxwell Dell are successfully able to do
the issue is who do they give it to and
so what they had to do is they had to
develop a device and the reason why is
because there's only a limited amount of
the vaccine considering the fact that it
had to be made quick fast and in a hurry
they'd a limited quantity so they can
test it if it works they can
mass-produce it what they end up doing
is they end up intending to to basically
analyze different individuals to test
them for this strain to see whether or
not they have this Spider Island virus
and it turns out that J jonah Jameson
has it J jonah Jameson basically becomes
spider-man and so what we get are all
these different situations that kind of
roll on top of one another in a sense
that we end up having anti-venom who's
going through just running through
Manhattan curing everybody of this fire
island virus that he comes across but we
also have the Avengers the Mighty
Avengers all these individuals putting
these sonic pulses around the city of
New York that would operate as these
kind of psychic fences so to speak so
that individuals can't leave they
basically can't walk out it'll end up
messing with them it'll operate his
offensive sorts and they'll basically
end up kind of staying corralled in New
York proper and so what we end up doing
is we join with with spider-man and we
join with carly cooper when they arrive
at a bank robbery and that's kind of the
cool thing years
why I like this is because it's kind of
Dan Slott showing us all these different
things that all happen at the same time
but I mean you have like the Avengers
you have the Mighty Avengers you have
New Avengers a whole nine yards all
these seven superhero teams you know
trying to corral this massive infection
you've got Reed Richards you get max
Modell the future foundation all working
on a cure and then you've got spider-man
doing what he's always done trying to
keep things at bay and stories like
major crossover events was that involves
spider-man usually always work this way
unless we're talking about an event that
takes it you know that goes off into
space or something like that or
threatens the entirety of the earth at
one time which is to say like a villain
shows up and it's just a threat to the
world instead of starting out small like
the city of Manhattan and working their
way out spider-man usually always plays
a smaller role during the onslaught saga
for example the spider-man wasn't really
facing off against onslaught per se
spider-man was facing off against a lot
of the Sentinels that onslaught was
using keep Manhattan in an in a state of
prison he was fighting off against
various villains that were using the
chaos as a chance to implement a whole
bunch of their own schemes and crimes
and so it's really cool to see a lot of
these things take place yet again in the
realm of sprite which is one of these is
why a lot of fans love him because
spider-man is basically Marvel's way of
reminding us that the small guy still
has issues of their own and spider-man
is still looking out for the small guy
this little bit becomes particularly
important when we deal with the arrival
of the Shocker and the reason why is
because of the Shocker entity as he
exists here basically has six arms and
our question is what in the hell
happened
why does the Shocker have six arms well
this is when we start getting into the
idea of a second phase of this and this
infection in the sense that individuals
who are exposed to the first phase
develop spider-man powers when it gets
to the second phase they start
physically mutated and that's what
happened with chakra when he was
infected his body began to physically
meet a to give him six arms it began to
meet him into an actual spider now what
Dan Slott is doing here is he's drawing
on the spider-man element of infinity
war movie nights who don't know during
the infinity war story arc when Adam
warlock 0 persona Magus was trying to
attain the Infinity Gauntlet by grabbing
all the different cosmic cubes from
different universes
what Magus ended up doing was creating
doppelgangers for the Earth's heroes in
order to keep them out of the way and so
were you had like a Wolverine
doppelganger you had a Reed Richards
doppelganger or a hope doppelganger so
on and so forth
spider-man had his doppelganger which
had six arms the issue is that that
doppelganger became so popular that
Marvel kind of had to roll him over and
after you know after the events of
infinity war we're done because people
love that idea the issue is that nobody
could ride him very well so eventually
they got rid of him but what we end up
doing is to basically start picking up
with all these different mutations and
this is when we learn who this
individual is is when we learn who this
unknown woman is that she's basically
someone called the Queen now if those of
you guys who don't know the Queen is a
woman named Adriana Soria I think it is
and she first appeared in spectacular
spider-man vol 2 number 15 I think she
was a character that was created for the
purpose of kind of stepping into this
new era of Peter Parker where Michael
was trying to kind of switch things
around move things around make him a
little more interesting it was that
whole hodgepodge of events leading into
one more day but it was this idea that
she was basically someone who had the
ability or had telepathy and basically
had what was called the insect gene and
what that meant was that she was able to
tap into and control individuals and
insects but the only individual she
could control were people who had insect
genes the problem with this was that her
being able to control them was
contingent on her knowing that they were
they were people with insect genes and
so the reason behind this whole thing
this entire spiral of Spider Island
event was for her to basically engineer
her own Kingdom now it's not the first
time she's tried this during that whole
weird era of Spider Man there was a
point where Peter Parker actually turned
into a giant spider it was weird as hell
but the whole notion was that she had
tried to kind of create a high for
herself for this since she had tried to
take over New York ultimately she was
defeated but in the instance where Peter
Parker had turned into a giant spider
and then eventually was transformed back
she had taken a husk a little form a
little piece of this this gene for Peter
she had taken it to miles Warren to the
jackal and that's what jackal used to
synthesize or I guess to create this
virus planted in these bedbugs and
turned the citizens of New York into
individuals with the powers of
spider-man and so what this would allow
the Queen to do is then turn around and
control those individuals because now
they all have an insect gene and so
because of this and what her intention
is is to literally just kind of create
her own army and that's exactly what's
happening with these secondary mutations
all these people who are beginning to
mutate are turning into giant spiders
that's literally what they are that is
turning into massive spiders but this is
going to allow the Queen to basically
begin the process of engineering her own
Kingdom to basically create her own her
own place of rule now the other cool
thing about this is that we actually end
up joining anti-venom and this is
the funny situation here because there's
a mishmash of things at work here is a
mishmash of plays going on all at the
same time in the sense that with spider
King having been having you know gone
against agent venom that when spider
King returns to the Queen as well as a
miles warrant this is not actually
spider King instead this is agent venom
posing as Spider King and that's why
this is one of those cool things is
because it's the ability of agent venom
to use the sin of the venom Samia to
kind of shape-shift to adjust himself
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
people love agent venom because it was
taking the venom simia and using it in a
way that hadn't really been used before
but in addition to all of this these
individuals who were beginning to
physically manifest who are beginning to
physically mutate I actually end up
going to Our Lady of Saints Church and
grabbing anti-venom and the reason why
is because word has reached their ears
that anti-venom has the ability to cure
people of their infection now this is
why we did the whole thing of like you
know of anti-venom and a Punisher
team-up the amazing spider-man and the
anti-venom team-up the origin of
anti-venom because this was Dan Slott
bringing this redemption of Eddie Brock
into full view basically bringing it all
the way back around again it was Dan
Slott saying hey look this is how why
Eddie Brock is basically a good guy is
him trying to do the right thing because
he looks at all these individuals and he
says you poor cast off Souls come to
Papa anti-venom I have the cure to what
ails you and it's basically him curing
people is him saying look I'm a good guy
I'm curing every last one of these
individuals
I'm literally saving New York now
that'll become a lot more important than
it seems right now but it's a really
really interesting set of events because
for Peter Parker for spider-man himself
it's absolute pandemonium and it's chaos
because among all these giant spiders
are Carly Cooper now while he's trying
to track her down while he's trying to
stop these giant spiders that are
attacking individuals one of them
basically begins to lay waste to the
vehicle or to the to the motorcade of
jage onna Jamison and this is kind of
cool because what happens is Jameson
refuses to be saved by Peter Parker yet
again keep in mind Jameson has always
housed a hatred for Peter Parker but in
Jameson's mind that is a--the Marla is
tied into Peter Parker's actions and of
course Marla told him in her final
moments do not succumb to hate do not
blame spider-man do not blame Alastair
smite spiders later do not blame any of
those just accept the fact that
sometimes things like this happen and
there's nothing we can really do to stop
it
and so what is not happening here is
that in the midst of all this J jonah
Jameson reveals the fact that he has
spider powers he grabs Peter Parker and
he says we're going back
the emergency command center we're going
to find a way to get over this I think I
have an ace in the hole this is kind of
cool because this is an uneasy alliance
between Jay jonah Jameson and spider-man
if it was Jameson's way he just throw
spider-man and Jalen call it a day
but he needs spider-man he needs
spider-man here because he's basically
the only individual present in New York
that has spider powers that can use them
effectively everybody else that has
spider powers are turning into giant
spider monsters and so what we do is we
pick up with Jay jonah Jameson basically
interrogating Alastair Smith and Smith
is a little cryptic here because first
of all he says look man like the whole
reason why I'm Spider Slayer is because
you and your stupid tabloid led to the
death of my father they led to the
destruction of my career they led to me
becoming a bad guy all I want is revenge
on you but then it's also Alastair Smith
saying hey I got my revenge because this
is when he realizes the only reason Jay
jonah Jameson would come to him after
Smith killed Jameson's wife is because
Jameson himself is infected and so it's
like Alastair Smith getting the revenge
that he always wanted now this comes to
bear this a little bit of hubris on
Smith's behalf comes to bear when the
Queen begins to use her telepathy and
start talking to Jay jonah Jameson
begins to infiltrate his mind and she
basically appears as the wife of Jay
John Jameson who says remember how I
told you not to blame yourself I told
you not to blame spider-man don't blame
Alastair Smith I lied
kill them all and so it's so cool
because then Jay jonah Jameson starts to
lose his mind now again we get a little
bit more of this kind of a montage this
little bit of a hodgepodge but we have
Locke hat and we have few of the
ground-level heroes really trying to
protect some of these sonic devices for
the purpose of keeping everybody
corralled in New York we have agent
venom going against anti-venom which is
actually pretty amazing like it's pretty
badass we also end up having Mary Jane
Watson develop spider powers on her own
and so because of this we ultimately
pick up with agent venom having to feed
it defeated anti-venom as far as I'm
aware we don't see it but it may end up
being the best part of the venom die and
I'll have to double check on that but
anti-venom is essentially defeated here
now the irony of all this is that agent
venom didn't ask any questions he just
showed up and started attacking
anti-venom and was just like you're
coming with me
and it's kind of funny because when
anti-venom when Eddie Brock is talking
to Reed Richards you know he's like hey
look I would have come willingly all you
had to do was tell me what it is that
you wanted if what you wanted was to
basically use me as a way to synthesize
a cure that I would have been fine with
that and Reed Richards says one glad
you're on board man because we're
literally taking the entire anti-venom
Cynthia and Eddie Brock's response is
like what
and he's like yeah man you're not gonna
be able to be anti-venom anymore now
keep in mind this is Dan Slott kind of
wrapping this up this is Dan Slott
saying hey guys look for the time being
at least as far as I'm aware for the
time being this is the beginning in the
end of anti-venom it's kind of wrapping
these things up sort of bringing things
to a close because member the entire
anti-venom Park was designed for the
sole purpose of redeeming Eddie Brock in
the eyes of counter book fans in the
eyes of of really you know the the
superhero landscape within Marvel comets
itself now of course with J John Jameson
you know mutating freaking out under the
influence of the Queen he immediately
attacks Alastair smite and in this last
couple seconds you know with love the
last few seconds of life that he has
left Alastair Smythe says you have
everything you need to defeat these
giant spiders you already have your army
all you have to do is figure out a way
to tap into it and use it for your own
ends alright so picking up with Spider
Island part 2 I know a lot of gonna be
like no the good thing is that this
video came out within hours of the last
video so don't be giving me no hard
times about cliffhangers don't be givin
me a hard time but no clipping so what
we ended up doing what we end up doing
here is we basically pick up kind of
continuing where we left off we join
Mary Jane Watson facing off against some
of these guys but also using her using
her own webbing her own spider abilities
but the cool thing about this is that
you know within our Lady of Saints
Church where these individuals were
hanging out again they were just kind of
left there when agent venom was able to
succeed in defeating anti-venom Mary
Jane Watson begins to gain a better
understanding of what it means to be
spider-man and that's one of the
interesting things about this is because
this never really seemed to be a concept
that was explored this because the fact
that I'm not aware of Mary Jane Watson
ever having spider powers on this level
instead before the events of one more
day and even after the events of one
more day where she still knew the
identity of Peter Parker the only real
exposure she had to what it meant to be
spider-man was basically the toll that
it would take on Peter Parker having to
walk the nice edge of keeping his
identity secret while simultaneously
trying to make sure that he could be an
effective hero and so because of this
she's coming to it from the other side
of the coin she's seen what it means
having to pull her punches you know
facing off against a lot of these these
giant spiders recognizing that they're
people at the same time and they could
possibly be cured and so as her
realizing that she basically has to stop
these spiders from killing those humans
that haven't done that haven't mutated
while simultaneously not killing the
spiders and so again it's this very
interesting situation because
she has to kind of be a savior and a and
and not a killer at the same time if
that makes any sense but again we also
end up joining with the Queen and the
reason why is because of the fact that
Reed Richards is using this cure on son
Johnny remember so Johnny is basically a
member of a horizon labs one of the
people who is infected but almost
immediately after this cure begins to
develop after almost immediately after
it's derived the Queen begins to start
going through all these individuals who
have this this insect gene by way of
this Spider Island virus and eventually
is it well it's happened - so Johnny
when she realizes so Johnny is in
horizon labs and Reed Richards and his
team have synthesized a cure and so
using said Johnny she basically kind of
forces the physical mutation and the
result is that so Johnny kind of gets
out of control for a second but is
almost immediately subdued by a
combination of Jessica drew spider woman
and Reed Richards himself now with
regards to the injection of this cure
this is when the Queen starts to realize
how this cure is legitimate and that if
it's mass-produced it was turned into
like an aerosol if it goes airborne
it'll literally take away everything
that Queen's been working for all of her
power will basically be gone and so what
happens is Jack Olsen's came on a
mission to horizon labs for the purpose
of basically contaminating this cure
making sure that it can never go into
full-blown use now at this point what we
also do is we basically join the man in
the sixth rim we only get a glimpse here
but we join a man in the six room this
unknown third individual who was helpful
and basically creating a cure by way of
Reed Richards and max Modell and what we
end up finding out is that this third
man is Michael Morbius now Michael
Morbius being rolled into this story is
not an accident remember prior to
Michael Morbius you know gaining his
infection becoming a living vampire he
was a Nobel winning biochemist and so
he's really like one of the best people
that you would want he's really one of
the top minds when it comes to
biochemistry when it comes to biological
contaminants when it comes to creating a
cure for virtually anything the other
half of this isn't Michael Morbius has
always tried to find a way to cure
himself as though it creates a really
interesting situation because it's kind
of Michael Morbius offering some measure
of atonement in addition to this Michael
Morbius is just a fan favorite so why
not have him in the story he'll like it
it just works
it's really cool to see him there
through a lot of fans are just like yeah
Michael Morbius really good to see a lot
of them but we get to see enough of him
here now of course the other funny thing
is that we also end up joining madam lab
Julia carpenter who like appears to Reed
Richards and is like you've put these
psychic inhibitors around the city of
New York
take them down and then she leaves and
that's it she was like shows up she's
like fix it now and then just leaves and
it's kind of funny this is like this
quick little pop-up situation here but
what this does is it allows Dan Slott to
begin segwang into the final act of this
story and what I mean here is that we're
these psychic blocks were put in place
for the purpose of basically removing
people's ability to to leave the city of
New York one is up happening is that
witness the psychic inhibitor horizon
labs kind of has to play this balancing
act or they have to sit down they have
to say okay fine look we cannot take
down the psychic inhibitors in their
entirety because if we if we do this
infection will spread we have a cure but
if they just scattered to the four
corners of the world well suddenly we're
stretched too thin and there's no
stopping this contagion but if we keep
it here in New York then it's easier to
control it's easier to cure and so what
happens is horizon labs uses some of the
knowledge of Peter Parker that he had
given them over the course of his
experience and they basically kind of
modify the signal to send it out in a
way that basically restores Peter
Parker's spider sense now with regards
to the restoration of Peter Parker
spider sense this coincides with his
conflict with Kaine and the reason why
is because the jackal had sent Caine to
Horizon laughter the purpose of
contaminating this cure and so when
Peter Parker had traveled back to
Horizon labs
he was basically forced to face off
against Kay now again this is mutated
this is keen all kinds of screwed up the
full fruition of where his character was
going to be because of his unstable
genes and so because of this during the
conflict when out Peter Parker's when is
when a spider since is restored to him
the result is a he's able to basically
outwit and outmaneuver Kaine and
virtually every feasible sense and this
is one of the reasons why it works is
because pain has you know he's stronger
he's faster he's more durable than
spider-man but spider-man basically is
able to use his way of the spider
kung-fu in conjunction with a spider
sense and make himself virtually
untouchable now none of this really
matters just because of the fact Peter
Parker basically sends cane flying into
the VAT of anti-venom you know I'm and
essentially just kind of cures him and
returns him to his normal appearance but
what Dan Slott was doing with this was
basically saying this whole nonsense
about cane being like a weird physical
spider thing this has gone far enough
like we need to we need either like well
pardon my language we need a poo already
to get off the pot like we got to do
something with it and so Dan sloths like
we're just going to basically send him
off like what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna send him off to the
cornfields he's gonna be scarred spider
but in order for us to pull that off
what we need to do is cure him we need
to basically make his make his body
physically perfect so that instead of
having these corrupted genes the way he
did you know as part of a part of Clone
Saga that instead what he's gonna do is
he's going to have to basically perfect
the genes is basically what's gonna
happen here now what we end up doing is
we end up finding out that because of
the fact that this signal has been
modified that is restored this spider
sends a Peter Parker Dan Slott begins to
draw on the web of life and destiny
because keep in mind when the web of
life in destiny was introduced in Marvel
Comics it was modifying spider-man's
mythos prior to that point it was always
believed that spider-man's powers his
strength agility speed you know spiders
and so on and so forth
all those just came from just the
radiation in his blood the web of life
and destiny said no that's not the case
Peter Parker is basically an avatar he
he more or less is a character that
reflects a kind of a representation of
these totems you know these duh he's
basically uh I guess a herald of the web
and life and definitely a destiny if
that makes any sense all that really
means is that he derives his powers
directly from the web of life and
destiny well so does the queen and so
does Madame web and so by giving Peter
Parker his spider sense back the Queen
now has full access to her abilities and
Madame web has full access to her
abilities but we also find out is that
this giant weird spider monster that
appeared at the beginning of the story
was Steve Rogers that Steve Rogers had
been taken by jackal he had been mutated
and turned into a servant of the Queen
now of course he had since been turned
back but the idea here is that he's
basically kind of this last man standing
trying to face off against the Queen
herself and breve her ruled out the
issue with this is that with the Queen
having full access to her powers she
goes into her full form and what she
becomes is an omega-level threat now
this is something that I want to draw
your attention to because in Marvel
Comics when it comes to the idea of like
omega-level mutant omega-level threats
this is how they're confirmed for
example we saw in like an uncanny x-men
number 513 I posted about this on
Twitter we saw that Emma Frost was
confirmed as an omega-level mutant and
x-men vol 2 issue numbers 70 or
something like that Charles Xavier was
confirmed to be an alpha level mutant
these are how things end up playing out
that there's individuals whose status
within the Marvel community is confirmed
now when it comes to like Omega level
threats those are basically people that
have the power of Omega low mutants but
they're not mutants that's all that
means us that's the only difference it's
just kind of an interchangeable
term but the idea is that we also have
Peter Parker trying to maintain this
ruse that he and spider-man are two
distinctly different individuals because
in the mind of Peter Parker he hasn't
revealed his identity to anybody yet no
one knows who he is
and so to the eyes of everybody except
for like Reed Richards and a handful of
others that don't that know his secret
identity when they see Kayne Parker
walking around in the spider-man costume
while simultaneously seeing him standing
alongside Peter Parker well then they
have no reason to believe that Peter
Parker and spider-man are one in the
same is basically Peters ruse this was
his way of kind of clear in the air when
everybody with horizon Labs is there and
as him saying hey look guys see like me
and spider-man are two distinctly
different people and so because of this
we basically pick up with kind of like
this last man battle I mean you have
really you know you have like Kaine
Parker you have you have Peter Parker
you have all these guys that are facing
off against you know against the queen
spider but what is up happening is Peter
Parker begins to draw on what it was
that else there's some I said you have
all the resources that you need in order
to take down all these different spiders
in the Queen all you have to do is
harness them effectively and that's when
Peter recalls back to the octobots of
Doctor Octopus the Doctor Octopus would
use a helmet to control all these little
individual BOTS Peter Parker races back
to the precinct alongside Mary Jane
Watson puts the helmet on and begins
using all these different octobots
for the purpose of trying to take out
the Queen and all these other
individuals who are infected with this
virus the problem with this is this
queen is wildly powerful in terms of her
abilities and so when is up happening
here as you basically end up seeing
Kaine doing what needs to be done where
Peter Parker has this moral code and
Peter Parker says we do not kill we need
to incapacitate her we need to take her
out and then take her prisoner Kaine
says no the only way that we can deal
with this is to take this woman out is
to eliminate her in her entirety and
that's what Dan slots drawing on here
with the idea of Kaine because remember
going all the way back to kono saga when
he first showed up cane was designed to
be this character who was a moral he
wasn't really a good guy he wasn't
really a bad guy he had his own moral
compass he would kill if he needed to he
would save people if he needed to he was
willing to go further than Peter Parker
was and so what happens as the story
basically comes to a close is that Kaine
wipes out the Spider Queen basically
eliminates her in her entirety and so
with the entire spider the spider ion
have been kind of winding down the cure
is basically synthesized it's mass
distributed to everybody to the point
that everybody kind of begins to line
down from their infection and so what
this does is this leads into the
epilogue of Spider Island which begins
to wrap up all these loose ends it's Dan
Slott going through and saying okay
here's
we stand with a spider-man mythos going
forward after the events of Spider
Island
okay so picking up with the epilogue to
Spider Island this is actually really
kind of cool the whole basis from what I
could tell anyway the whole basis behind
Spider Island was really kind of like
what the early bit of Dance Lots run was
leading up to and this since there was
this idea of the dance looked around I
said there's a lot of things in the
spider-man mythos and I don't really
care for that was done by committee
because remember when Dan Slott first
became part of this writing committee
after the events of one more day it was
everybody's gonna be part and parcel to
this you know there's gonna be there's a
lot of fingers in this story that's
being told it wasn't just Dan Slott
doing what Dan Slott wanted to do but
having the ability to take over the
title on his own and do whatever it is
that he wanted to do granted him the
opportunity to say okay let's just clear
out all the stuff that I don't like
let's get rid of all the things I don't
want to that I don't want to have in the
spider-man mythos let's rectify all this
stuff and that's exactly what happens
here but it also sends out some threads
for future stories that will come later
on down the line specifically superior
spider-man so what we do is he basically
just kind of pick up with the aftermath
I mean the story is called naked city
and it's kind of funny here I mean
there's all these different superheroes
in the in the Marvel Universe who were
all giant spiders you know during the
events of Spider Island and it's kind of
funny here you know because it's like
everybody's kind of recovering and it
rotties shocked that they were naked the
only person who doesn't care is Hercules
and Hercules is like yes look upon my
visage with envious eyes male
superheroes it's it's really kind of
this funny situation that's one of the
things I love so much about his
character because he's just kind of like
I'm in my natural form like I am you
ladies you know I am the god of strength
they don't call me a giant for no reason
and it's uh it all seriousness it's just
one of these funny little one of these
funny little things again it's just kind
of it's it's really just cleanup you
know it's just it's cleaning things up
getting things sorted out getting things
back in order and so the idea here is
that we pick up with Mary Jane Watson
and Peter Parker and this is one of the
things that's kind of cool because Dan
Slott sort of takes this moment between
the two of them and it's not really Dan
Slott saying hey we're gonna get them
back together again it's Dan Slott
saying hey these two share a connection
that no one else really shares and
that's true you know even within the the
spider-man mythos that's true you know
the fact that they did it for so long
she was one of the first people to know
about his secret identity so on and so
forth but outside of the comic we as the
reader look at that and it's like even
if they're only really good friends for
us is the reader for people who followed
spider-man there's a
connection between the two of them that
no one else has but the stories that
have been written about Mary Jane Watson
about Peter Parker have had their ups
and downs they've been married they
broke up their marriage was nullified by
Mephisto there's all kinds of things
that go on with their story and so a lot
of people look at that and say look at
the legacy that was forged between these
two and it's really dance-a-lot kind of
pointing at that a stand slap saying hey
they're showing a rooftop moment and it
represents everything that they've been
through up to this point the other half
of this is that in the middle of the
conversation Peter Parker especially has
to bail out because you know Aunt May's
grabbing his attention when she and J
jonah Jameson senior are finally making
their way off to Boston officially
leaving New York after the events of
Spider Island and this is when we
learned that Mary Jane Watson retain her
spider powers and so it's really kind of
cool you know to ask the question what
kind of stories are we gonna see but
again this whole idea of anti-venom you
know for example the idea that Eddie
Brock was looking for atonement for spaz
acts when he was a villain comes to
fruition when Reed Richards pops up on
TV now again keep in mind when it comes
to the model landscape Reed Richards how
he's viewed within Marvel Comics his
house he is how he's viewed outside of
Marvel Comics within the Marvel Comics
universe it's like Reed Richards one of
the smartest men in the world everybody
respects him he's an explorer the
superheroes love him when it comes to us
as readers outside of comics just like
the Fantastic Four the first family of
Marvel the Fantastic Four sat the
groundwork for the Avengers force
where's all these different teams that
would come later on down the line
you know guardians of the galaxy they
were the template behind that the legacy
characters and so when Reed Richards
shows up on TV and says New York was
saved because of the actions of Eddie
Brock
well then any Brock's a good guy now and
there's no arguing that point it's just
the way it is and it's really cool
because that's the kind of kind of
respect that Reed Richards commands from
people in New York from the superhero
community so on and so forth but again
it's just kind of wrapping up a few
loose ends here you know in the sense
that Jay jonah Jameson is having a drink
with Robbie Robertson again they're kind
of on a kind of on different terms here
in terms of you know Jay jonah Jameson
being mayor of New York Robbie Robertson
running frontline now but it's also this
idea that Jay jonah Jameson still
doesn't seem to want to give up the
notion that Peter Parker that that
spider-man saved the city he kind of
wants to hang on to his anger hang on to
his hatred for all this and at the end
of the day Roger Robertson says dude
you've got to give spider-man a break
you know he was basically the key to
saving the city he's one of the people
that helped save the entirety of the
city and so in the end you know jgm
Jameson's like fine I'll give them a
break you know I will I'll cut him a
break I'll make a call and we'll see
what happens
we have Peter Parker help me some guys
on the bridge um you know get things
cleared up you know get things cleared
out it's just kind of this cool little
moment the problem is that after Peters
done saying his goodbyes to Aunt May
after she and JJ Jameson leave for
Boston he gets back home to the
apartment with Carly Cooper and this is
really where Dan Slott begins to sort of
wrap things up between the two because
Carly Cooper's breaking up with him now
this is what I said it was important
that we had to keep in mind the whole
idea of Peter Parker going on TV and
saying I'm spider-man you know during
the events of Spider Island because
Carly Cooper has figured out his secret
identity and that was not supposed to
happen remember it's almost like those
you know it's almost like a Harry Potter
universe right you know when those
wizards of stuff Castle spells somebody
walks up with something they're not
supposed to walk up to and then suddenly
they remember they're supposed to go do
something else
the spell is much like that that dr.
strange that I cast in the sense that
unless Peter Parker went to Carly Cooper
and said you know took off his mask and
said hey look I'm spider-man or revealed
his identity to who of what to her
individually or she just walked up on
him while he was changing into his
spider-man costume she's not supposed to
know no one is supposed to know but she
knows and what she says is I'm a
forensic scientist my job is to put the
pieces together and what she says is
when Spider Island happened and I was
gaining my spider powers for the first
time and everybody in the city was
getting those spider powers for the
first time you were the only one that
knew exactly how to use them you were
the only one that slid right into the
role and knew it perfect and she even
goes back if you guys remember it with
Volume one in Big Time she goes back and
says when we were hanging out and that
was showing you how to roller-skate you
didn't know how to roller-skate you were
trying to figure it out she was like
that's what you should have done when
you were tricking me and that's that's
the biggest issue for her is not that
Peter Parker spider-man it's the fact
that he lied to her with Carly Cooper
her family's mired in in deceit her
family's mired in people keeping their
own secrets with her going to Peter
Parker when they first started getting
together her her her whole thing was you
better know what you're doing and you
better not lie and Peter Parker lied to
her duped her about his identity now
granted this was done by Peter for the
safety of all I mean that was something
that was established during the events
of civil war that was the whole crux
when Peter Parker went on stage during
the events of civil war and said hey
everybody my name is Peter Parker I'm
revealing my identity because I trust a
man when he says superheroes who come
forward and register with shield will
not have to worry about their families
being put in danger that was exactly
what happened as soon as Peter Parker
revealed his identity he walked out
people tried to attack him they tried to
attack Aunt May they tried to attack me
in Watson and so in response to this
when civil war was over when it was all
said and done after the events of one
more day and all that kind of good stuff
when Peter Parker went to dr. strange
you know in the post-civil war landscape
and said I want to make sure no one
knows what my identity is Doctor Strange
casts a spell and it was done to make
sure that if Peter Parker for some
reason his identity was dumped out that
he wouldn't have to worry about that he
would have to worry about people
figuring out who he is he wouldn't have
to worry about his friends and family
being put in danger the issue with all
this is that for Carly Cooper it just
doesn't it doesn't resonate
she just doesn't grasp but at the end of
the day she's just like you lied to me
and so ultimately she says we're done
we're over with now what follows this is
actually kind of weak to be honest it's
actually kind of a weak way to do this
what dr. strange you know when Peter
Parker goes to dr. strange and says why
did she know my secret identity no one
was supposed to know what in the heck
happened dr. strange says when you went
on TV and told people I'm Peter Parker
I have spider powers you basically told
everybody you were spider-man you undid
the spell or at least didn't really undo
it but make it weak or make it possible
for people to know who he was
it's not like he was wearing a
spider-man mask and went on TV like you
did during Civil War take his mask off
and say I'm spider-man but it was almost
the same thing and because that if we
can dispel to a degree and people can
start figuring out his identity now this
was basically Dan Slott coming back and
saying okay let's get things sorted out
let's make things reasonable let's set
this for the purpose of making
spider-man's stories a little more
dangerous because that was always kind
of an intrinsic value of Peter Parker
stories someone somewhere may figure out
his identity and if they do what happens
like that was always kind of the basis
behind it so it was basically beefing up
the number of people in his rogues
gallery who could know who he is taking
it beyond Jack well you know getting
into all these different individuals and
setting the stage for superior
spider-man and so what we end up doing
is we sort of transition to this last
little bit of a send-off with Madame web
again you know Julia carpenter Madame
web being able to see the future and so
on she really just kind of sits down
with with Peter and she says look you
know what you are given here is it is a
chance to basically start over you know
you were given or you you had this last
little vial of the Cure from max Modell
if you take this it will cure you of
your spider powers you will no longer be
spider-man you will be Peter Parker and
you will be able to live a regular life
she says the web of life and destiny
chooses avatars for the totems your
spider-man because the web of life and
destiny chose you to be spider-man if
you walk away
someone else can take your place it
could be Ben Riley it could be Kane
Parker it could be any number of people
it could be a random guy off the street
it's her basically saying you have an
out you have a chance to walk away this
is Dan Slott toying with the notion that
Peter Parker might not be spider-man
anymore but in the end he says no he
says I'm going to stay spider-man I'm
gonna be spider-man of course we would
have a hard time envisioning a scenario
where Peter Parker was never spotted a
man again I have a hard time imagining a
situation where model would release a
story where Peter Parker on the main
Marvel Universe worse like Peter Parker
is never gonna be spider-man again like
his is gonna be somebody else like they
they kill off Peter Parker and replace
him with Miles Welles that'll never
happen it's like eliminating Superman
and having him gone forever
and never bringing him back in the end
Peter Parker's a legacy character he's
he's so significant to the success of
Marvel Comics and one of their
best-selling titles if that happened
they'd be on the verge of destroying
their entire comic book line just
because of one individual person is a
bold statement but it's a statement that
I think is actually pretty accurate here
and so in the end we pick up with Mary
Jane Watson and and this is kind of the
cool thing is because Peters also
learning that Mary Jane still has her
powers to a degree but it's also kind of
reconciling these two things and even
then you know he sits down and he talks
with Mary Jane about how Peter you know
how he and Carly have basically broken
up now again dance lots kind of twing
here he's like well maybe while they get
together won't they get together and
we're really not given an answer here
we're really not given an answer on
whether or not the two of them will end
up getting back together again instead
the conversation kind of deviates
towards the idea that Peter Parker feels
like well his actions will just go
unnoticed
that'll just be another instance of
Peter saving the city and no one will
really care that much for Mary Jane
Watson says now the Empire State
Building has been letting up in
celebration of you your colors it's the
city of New York saying thank you it's
the city of New York basically saying
thank you spider-man
for saving our city for keeping us alive
and it is cool it's a really great way
because what this does is basically wrap
up like the first half of Dance Lots run
the first part of dance launch one is
him clearing all that stuff out and
saying okay guys now we basically get to
start over again
now we officially get into what it is
that I wanted to do now we officially
get into everything leading up into
superior spider-man going into
spider-verse going into all-new
all-different amazing spider-man all
that kind of good stuff okay so I'll be
honest with you guys when dying wish
first came out I have never with the
exception of one more day
in terms of like modern spider-man
history I've never even heard of a more
divisive story than that's people there
were people out there who hated superior
spider-man they were just like no no
Peter Parker stays fine and that's just
what it's always Peter Parker this is
this needs to be Peter Parker like they
were getting so bent out of shape but
there were other people like me who
thought it was amazing it was just like
this is this is awesome so we're gonna
run over this we will let you guys
decide now in terms of like how happy
will time look like a lot of people say
this is the actual prelude to superior
spider-man I consider it part of
superior spider-man I mean I consider it
to be you know a part of the main thing
because I think it makes it more
cohesive I think it makes it more of
like a cohesive thing plus if you go and
buy superior spider-man you usually kind
of get you know dying dying which thrown
in but I really enjoyed this story
because what this does is it initially
just kind of picks up with with
spider-man Peter Parker right and there
were a few stories that took place in
between Spider Island and this but to me
those stories weren't particularly
interesting there were just moments in
those stories that were significant but
I found it very difficult to to bring
myself to run over the entirety of like
ends of the earth just for like one
moment so it was it was kind of a over
year situation but of course you know
this is cool because it almost seems
like a backed a back-to-basics for
spider-man right he's just going around
he's doing a spider-man thing you save
me people you know he kind of realizes
that he's got a scar on his face from an
attack that he had when he was going
against the goblins you know someone so
forth but he's kind of going through his
messages this is this is where things
get a little weird because something
seems a bit off right like he's getting
few messages you know he gets messages
from Mary Jane Watson beware Mary Jane
is like hey look at you come into the
club tonight he gets messages from from
max Modell saying hey you're your review
that's coming up you know for for
horizon lives and you know he's got time
that he has to spend with up with on May
and if so on someone so his life is
really packed to the brim and of course
it's kind of cool cuz he's going through
he's you know remaking his eyes his
spider webbing fluid is so on and so
forth but things start to get a little
funny when he encounters Mary Jane at
her club and what he does is he really
kind of approaches her and he says like
hey look we've been dancing around this
long enough it's time that we get back
together now this was crazy because it
was it was Dan Slott kind of toying with
the idea that Mary Jane Watson to Peter
Parker we're gonna get back to
again and in fact this is like one of
the things that that like a like the
die-hard fans wanted so much more they
really really really wanted Mary Jane
Watson and they wanted Peter Parker to
get back together he and they really
wanted them to be reunited but in a lot
of ways it was just kind of like Marvel
he basically said that's never going to
happen it so the idea was well maybe Dan
Slott will allow to have maybe dance
that will be the reason why it does
happen of course it doesn't really seem
to be the case it's sad you know it's
just kind of like hey look we got to go
hang out with you grow up man yada yada
yada but of course you know spending
time with Aunt May is also interrupted
by the fact that he's getting a request
to basically see Doctor Octopus Doctor
Octopus is calling him by name Peter
Parker and so of course he ends up
meeting with the New Avengers you know
Captain America and and Wolverine and so
on and then shows up there now this is
where things get crazy because when I
was going through this it was just like
when were originally reading this it was
like what in the world is going on but
it also seemed like Dan Slott was paying
inappropriate tribute right I mean
Doctor Octopus is basically dying that's
when the gist of his character really
ever since the events of spider-man Big
Time he's just been in the background
and he's been dying he's been
orchestrating plans here and there but
the plans really seem to be just his
attempt to cut in you know to to
implement one final successful campaign
before he passed on and this moment
seemed to be kind of Dan Slott sitting
down and saying okay look doctor
octopus's died he's really spider-man's
most formidable foe with the exception
of maybe venom ER or carnage but in
terms of long-standing villains you know
he's one of spider-man's oldest and most
dangerous foes it's really just the
right thing to do it's really just the
right thing to do a symbol you know to
have Doctor Octopus and spider-man do it
ascend off to one another but what ends
up happening is we find out that this is
not Doctor Octopus this is Peter Parker
their minds have been swapped and Peter
Parker and really spider-man's just like
yeah I have all your memories all your
experiences everything that makes you
who you are is now me I look like you
everyone believes you're being you are
Doctor Octopus let me tell you something
about Court when this reveal came out it
was like what like holy cow it was
mind-blowing because he like Doctor
Octopus started because he's only got a
few hours left you know any starts he
basically you know begins a process of
die you know they're trying to keep him
alive as best they can but Peter Parker
dice Martin I just kind of leaves and
he's like well that's that he just
basically just kind of takes off it's so
one of what we do is basically pick up
with the second half
of dying wish and really I guess the
first half is kind of a prelude but we
basically pick up with you know dying
wish proper and what dying wish does is
it answers the questions how in the
world did this happen how did Doctor
Octopus manage to swap minds with Peter
Parker because remember this just came
out of left field it was just suddenly
Peter Parker's mind is in the body of
Doctor Octopus and the mana doctor
octopus's in the body of Peter Parker
and so it was like what in the heck
happened that went through all this well
of course
initially it picks up with Peter Parker
worrying about what things may happen
what Doctor Octopus might do what's
ironic about this is a doctor octopus's
to do any of those things in fact I
would say the Doctor Octopus is
spider-man it's probably better than
Peter Parker my Doctor Octopus is as
spider-man better than I like Peter
Parker is spider-man it was interesting
had it gone on long enough that novelty
would have worn off but for what a
superior spider-man was I think he was
better than than Peter Parker but of
course his main concern is that Doctor
Octopus is basically going to swindle
his friends and family you know that
he's going to force himself onto Mary
Jane Watson he's going to steal the
fortune or steal the money of of Jay
jonah Jameson senior and Aunt May he's
gonna kill a lot of the superhero
friends because he has access to the
Avengers mansion and they don't know
that they don't know that this is Doctor
Octopus he goes through and starts
experiencing the memories of Doctor
Octopus doc Ock's abusive father the
first time the Doctor Octopus became
Doctor Octopus the time that Doc Ock and
I may got together physically physically
together but then he also begin this is
are we gonna go into the whole idea oh
how it is a Doctor Octopus is able to
pull off the mind swap and what ended up
happening is of course Doctor Octopus
had a helmet of sorts that was used to
basically control these little nanobots
that he had that went all the way back
to spider-man big Tod and of course
Peter Parker had taken this this device
to control these nanobot so you know
basically brain doctor octopus's various
campaigns to an end but he had also
taken the technology of the device and
incorporated in his own spider armor
outfit and what this did is it gave
Doctor Octopus
a direct line into the mind of Peter
Parker he literally opened the door for
Doc Ock and that's what's so cool about
this story it shows how smart Doctor
Octopus is he was planning ahead all
these campaigns that he had was he
realized he was I was with a sole
purpose of basically finding a way to
enter to map Peter Parker's mind and
that's exactly what he did he just
sorted going through and mapping
peter parker's mark and when the
opportunity came he basically swapped
their bodies and nobody knew what was
going on it took place he lost him
nobody had any idea that that happened
and so the whole point of the whole
concept here is that Peter Parker is now
panicking because he has to find a way
to get back into his normal body well of
course this also coincides with Curt
Connors so the cool thing about this is
Dan Slott kind of pulling out all the
stops and he's really just kind of
yanking all these things out for example
he says that were previously the lizard
was believed to have just been this
mindless beast you know this this Hulk -
doc connors Bruce Banner that in truth
doc Connors mind is alive and well in
the body of the lizard the lizard is as
scientifically intelligent as doc
Connors was you know it's not a mindless
beast is an intelligent being inside an
incredible body doc Connors just can't
go back to the way he was before
but this is cool because this is
basically you know Connors spilling the
beans on who he is and what he's about
and it changes everything for Peter
Parker because in his mind he's like you
should go tell someone dr. Cottle doc
Connors is not the bad guy the lizard is
the bad guy tells someone what's going
on but of course then the question has
to be asked like who's gonna believe him
like who would believe him if he told
them that you know always really me doc
Connors decide the body of the lizard
who's going to believe him that if you
know who's gonna believe I mean I guess
maybe psychics could figure that out but
in truth it just creates a situation the
doc Connors really can't seem to get out
of it so what is up happening is Peter
Parker begins to sort of put two and two
together throw into the memories of dr.
octopus of Otto Octavius going through
his mind reading his memories you know
learning what he's about he begins to
realize that Doc Ock always had a
contingency plan for every situation if
he were ever captured whatever the case
may be he always had a contingency plan
in this instance he had a contingency
plan to reform the sinister six and
break himself out of the raft
I remember the raft is a prison that
exists really you know out in the middle
of nowhere it's no-man's land people who
were taken there are isolated from
virtually everyone there this design
explicitly for the purpose of keeping
villains in isolation but what he does
is he basically initiates a protocol
that was owned by dr. octopus that sets
in motion the reactivation of the
sinister six and this is when we get
hydro-man this is when we get you know
the Scorpion when we get all these
different guys coming together for the
purpose of getting dr. octopus out of
there of course again in their mind they
don't know it's Peter Parker they
believe that it's dr. octopus and that's
why this works so well because it's the
street crosses both sides you know with
this
mário it's where you know Doctor Octopus
can parade around and the MA
in the body of Peter Parker and people
believe that Doctor Octopus is Peter
Parker Peter Parker can parade around in
the body of Doctor Octopus such as it is
and lead people to believe that he's
actually Doctor Octopus so as we get
into superior spider-man again we're
kind of doing this little bit of a
preload here but really with suicide run
it's really necessary and that's kind of
the cool thing about this is that
suicide run gives us an idea of what
Doctor Octopus is going to do in the
body of Peter Parker and that was really
what was necessary about this story just
because of the fact that when you know
Dan Slott was kind of leading up to this
whole superior spider-man thing that
nobody really knew that it was coming it
was just dance a lot kind of saying what
he always does
oh this story's going to change things
forever and this story's going to change
the landscape of the spider-man mythos
and nothing's ever going to be the same
and it was cool to see it for what it
was I mean it was interesting to kind of
you know see how it all played out but
the very idea here was that we were
basically going to see what we were what
direction the stories would end up going
in you know of course the idea that
Doctor Octopus and Peter Parker have
presumably switched bodies forever and
that was really the the indication that
was left here at the tail end of this
story now keep him on in the last video
we had talked about how with their
bodies switched the mind of Peter Parker
was basically in the body of Doctor
Octopus who was moments away from dying
I mean he was just right around the
corner from death just knocking on his
door and so really Doc Ock had just kind
of considered himself home free no we're
gonna go ahead and call him superior
spider-man to go ahead and keep the keep
it easy to understand but superior
spider-man they kind of considered
himself home free you know and the idea
that he was like well I mean our bodies
are swabbed the body of dr. octopus is
gonna die Peter Parker is gonna die
inside that body and that will be it not
only that Peters biggest concern was
that superior spider-man would go around
and basically start doing things like
reforming a relationship with Mary Jane
Watson and that was kind of the crazy
thing because fans thought that was
gonna happen and in fact we get that
little bit of a teaser here one of the
first things we see is superior
spider-man
spending time with the Mary Jane and the
idea to the two of them are basically
going to get together or at least it
seems like it's gonna happen you know
she says look is this a date the two of
us being here together is this what I
think it is and Peter you know superior
is part of man's response is yes it's
exactly what you think it is we're
getting back together now
here superior spider-man's basically
alerted to the fact that Doctor Octopus
is broken out of his cell and that was
really the huge thing because of course
superior spider-man was always on the
lookout to see whether or not Peter
Parker was able to find a way to escape
his confines and that's exactly what
happened the issue with this is that you
know the the body of Doctor Octopus
again was moments from dying and so
Peter Parker does exactly what he needs
to do and basically just kind of jerks
the body awake basically you know kind
of bringing it back to life but in this
three minute period between the time
that he dies in the time that he comes
back he basically ends up visiting his
hometown and what he ends up seeing are
a lot of these individuals who had died
we end up seeing people like Gwen Stacy
captain Stacy the father when we end up
seeing these various individuals who
have played significant roles in the
life of Peter Parker but all of whom
have effectively passed on know more so
than that then Uncle Ben now this is one
of the greatest moments in the entirety
of the spider-man run I always
considered it as when you look at Uncle
Ben Uncle Ben is probably the most
important character in the life of Peter
Parker despite the fact that he's dead
and the reason why is because when Peter
first developed the powers of spider-man
when he was first bitten by a
radioactive spider he did what every
teenager does he got carried away he
made some foolish decisions you know he
kind of let his powers get the better of
them he got revenge on you know bullies
that were giving him a hard time he did
what any of us would have done but in
this path he lost sight of the fact that
his actions can also lead to inaction if
he doesn't act when he needs to someone
around him could basically lose their
life and that's what happened with Uncle
Ben and for years and years and years
and years Peter Parker was guilt ridden
he always sat around and said if only I
had done something Uncle Ben would still
have been alive but because of this but
this gift Peter this kind of last bit to
basically say goodbye this last little
instant some more let's just kind of
walk away you know to be told by Uncle
Ben I'm as proud of you as I ever could
be you've become every ounce of the hero
that I believed you that you could be
you've done proud you've done me proud
with your actions as a hero and that's
really what Peter needed that was the
motivation he needed to keep going on so
what this story does is it basically
just kind of transitions to you know
Peter in the body of Doctor Octopus
making his escape to a a to an
underground hideout but it's also this
idea that they're initially caught up to
by Carly now remember Carly is the
ex-girlfriend of Peter Parker but works
in the worse than in the police
department it so the initial idea here
for Peter is hey Carly
knows who I am Harley can help me solve
this problem now the issue with this
this is where Dan Slott really begins to
hit home with the idea of the you know
the whole body swapping thing is that to
Carly's eyes this is Doctor Octopus she
was at see Peter Parker she sees Doc Ock
she sees a bad guy she sees a villain
now where Peter Parker tries to say hey
look I can prove that it's me you and
Mary Jane Watson are the only two people
who know my identity Carly just kind of
blows an office says well Doctor Octopus
has figured out what's going on with
Peter Parker and the fight ensues and of
course she's incapacitated pretty
quickly remember Carly is just a regular
human being no extraordinary abilities
or anything like that but in light of
this superior spider-man basically
begins rounding up the friends and
family of Peter Parker and that's why
this is cool is because under the guise
of spider-man operating as Peter Parker
superior spider-man basically says hey
look we need to keep the guys safe right
you know me Doctor Octopus has escaped
from the raft
he's got moments left to live he's one
of spider-man's most formidable enemies
he knows that you guys associate with me
we need to find a way to keep you safe
and in the guise of keeping them safe he
basically turns them into hostages and
that's kind of the cool thing here is
because now he has lies on his side and
that's one of the biggest weaknesses or
even one of the biggest strengths of
Peter Parker depending on how you look
at it is that he will not kill unless he
absolutely has to that was one of the
huge significant moments in the renew
your vows story during singer wars when
he basically allowed venom to die in
fact he really kind of killed venom by
really doing nothing but it's kind of
letting the symbiote burn alive letting
you know letting venom essentially die
his inaction just kind of allowed those
events to happen but in Peter Parker's
mind it was what needed to be done it
was basically saving his family and so
what is up happening here is that when
Peter superior spider-man come face to
face it's kind of a slight bit of an
exchange here in there of course Peters
basically in this bunker out in the
middle of nowhere you know on this this
year's you know trash heap that you know
of course belong to Doctor Octopus but
the idea here is superior spider-man
says look if you want to play that game
that's the game that we can play you
know if you want to play this idea of
well you know me and I know you so on
and so forth mr. Peter spider-man
basically gives the location of doctor
octopus's hideout sending them directly
to Peter Parker now to be honest with
you guys the superior spider-man's
really terrified here and the reason why
is because Doc Ock has really had to
admit on a multitude of occasions that
Peter Parker is extremely intelligent
dare I say as intelligent if not more
intelligent than Doctor Octopus and
because of this
what is up happening here is you know
she Peter spider-man's terrified of the
idea that Peter will come back and
reclaim his body and so he's literally
just throwing every single thing he can
at him especially when you're spider-man
you can use the tools of the police on
your side you can use the Avengers on
your side
you basically have every single hero at
your disposal when you can go to them
and say Doctor Octopus is trying to kill
my friends and family you have to help
me they will go to the ends of the earth
in order to make sure that Peter Parker
and the ones that he loves are kept safe
now from here this is when we get into
Dan Slott really toying with the
spider-man fan base and we have Mary
Jane Watson going to meet with superior
spider-man again now of course this is
really just kind of you know a couple
people bumping heads who are both
extremely stubborn of course you know
Mary Jane is like look I can keep
hassling you or you can just come and
answer the door but when the two of them
start talking what is up happening is
Mary Jane just confesses her love for
Peter Parker she says look I absolutely
love you like I don't know if we're ever
gonna be anything I don't know this is
ever going anywhere I don't know if
we're fooling ourselves who cares but I
love you and what is up happening is the
two of them share a kiss now for those
individuals who were reading spider-man
and who had been around since the events
of one more day it was almost like oh my
god is it gonna have it was that whole
will they won't they think are they
gonna get together are they not gonna
get together it's Dan Slott gonna
finally come around to bringing them
back together now of course we know
that's not the case and in fact Dan
Slott said on Twitter repeatedly he's
never going to allow Mary Jane Watson
reason ever going to you never we're
never gonna see Mary Jane Watson
and Peter Parker getting back together
just strictly by editorial mandate
Marvel editorial does not want that to
happen Marvel does not want those two
characters getting together they want to
leave the past in the past despite the
fact that a lot of people really want to
see it take place apparently that's not
gonna happen at all instead the closest
we're ever going to see to Mary Jane
Watson in Peter Parker being a couple
again is in the ongoing renew your vows
story coming out of Marvel right now but
what is up happening here is Doctor
Octopus essentially traces down you know
superior spider-man so because of the
fact the superior spider-man when he
took the different you know friends and
family of Peter Parker to keep them safe
he basically thrown them in a room and
Avengers mansion but what is up
happening here is a pretty
straightforward fight I mean it's really
just kind of Dan Slott wrapping up a lot
of loose ends but between Peter Parker
and Doctor Octopus this is a this is an
insane fight is it's a fight in the
extreme and the reason why is because
Peters literally fighting for his life
if he ends up losing this battle he's
going to lose his identity Doctor
Octopus will go forward in the body of
Peter Parker presumably forever and
there will be no way for Peter to regain
his life everything he's been fighting
for it will have been lost now the cool
thing is that Peter is extremely
intelligent and he always has a back-up
plan in this instance his back-up plan
was to grab one of those little octobots
that allowed the mind swapping process
in the first place and reverse it on Doc
Ock meaning that you know this this bot
would allow them to switch their bodies
back to the way they're supposed to be
the issue here is that again Doctor
Octopus is also extremely intelligent
and so because of that he planned for
this possible eventualities and that's
one of the reasons why Doctor Octopus is
so formidable as a villain when it comes
to battling Peter Parker Doctor Octopus
usually always plans two three four five
steps ahead and so while I wouldn't go
as far as to say that he always defeats
Peter Parker he would present a
challenge for most anybody because he's
considered so many different variables
and taken almost all those variables
into account and so because of this one
is I'm happening is that this bot cannot
switch the bodies back Peter Parker is
effectively stuck in the body of Doctor
Octopus Doctor Octopus is in the body of
Peter Parker and this is when the story
seriously begins to become something
special what is up happening here is
that Doctor Octopus is sort of forced to
relive not only the great moments of a
Peter Parker's life but the terrible
moments of Peter Parker's life he begins
to really understand what it means to be
spider-man it's not just traipsing
around getting the girl having a great
time fighting on the Avengers there's a
lot of responsibility that goes into it
because in Peter Parker's mind every
single time he went out into a battle
every time he went on to a fight it was
always fighting for the people that he
cared about it was fighting for his
loved ones who was fighting for his
friends it was fighting for his family
the responsibilities that came along
with those things Doctor Octopus begins
to realize the weight that is now on his
shoulders with Peter Parker effectively
dying in the body of Doctor Octopus
Peter says look it's your responsibility
now you have
that power if you're going to become me
then you have to fight for the people
who deserve health you have to make sure
that the friends and family that I know
you have to make sure that the people
that I care about the people that
believe that you're me that they are
safe and so what this does is it
basically steps forward with this idea
that you know Doctor Octopus in the body
of Peter Parker is effectively going to
leave his criminal life behind he's
essentially going to become a good guy
and that's what makes this so great is
because this sets the stage for him
turning over a new leaf that's one of
the reasons why a lot of people look to
superior spider-man and said it really
is just a genuinely good story in their
minds Peter Parker will always be
spider-man it'll always be a Peter
Parker it'll always be a return to that
familiarity a return to that status quo
but when we get these small little
stories we get to see what it looks like
when somebody else's in the body of
Peter Parker is Doctor Octopus
legitimately a better spider-man than
Peter Parker is is he more intelligent
is he more capable is he able to do
greater things and we'll see that happen
we'll see the formation of what will
become Parker Industries going into
all-new auto from often we will see neo
the early formation of that company here
in superior spider-man we'll see the
introduction of Anna Marconi and ongoing
character and all-new all-different
amazing spider-man we will see her in
this story a lot of the things that you
guys are going to come and notice with
regards to the whole all-new
all-different spider-man landscape we're
going to see a lot of those things
growing here in superior spider-man and
then expanding outward from there going
into the main spider-man spider-man
series as well as the eventual reboot
with all-new all-different marvel but
again this is really just kind of
designed to show us what direction
things are going to go in and to be
quite honest I think superior
spider-man's probably one of the
greatest spider-man stories ever told I
love the direction that it goes and I
love the idea of Doctor Octopus trying
to be a good guy using his intelligence
as well as the fact that he's just kind
of a jerk but if you guys are new here
to comment to explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become four out of
the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all at it
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]